Sébastien Crosier, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Alors euh peut-être un un petit euh un
un petit parcours. Euh j'ai j'ai la
chance euh d'être né dans une famille
euh un peu atypique puisque j'ai eu un
un père qui a été euh un un des artisans
euh de la fabrication de la bombe
nucléaire dont dont nous fêterons demain
le 66e anniversaire. En tous les cas,
l'explosion de Gerboise bleue, la la
première bombe qu'on a fait exploser
dans le Sahara et d'une mère archéologue
en Égyptologie, donc 5000 ans en
arrière, ce qui évidemment
permet de d'avoir une une vision du
monde très très différente et très très
éclectique. Puis au-delà de ça, après
j'ai fait des études plus euh plus
traditionnelles euh classiques à à Stan.
Puis euh finalement une école
d'ingénieur à à
Main de la Vallée, au pôle Gustave
Effel. Euh et en parallèle à Carls Rouer
euh au kit au Carls Rouer Institute
Technologie euh dans une spécialité euh
tout à fait euh euh on va dire Loufoc
euh pour l'époque puisque j'ai fait une
spécialisation intelligence artificielle
euh et euh en dominante et en secondaire
télécommunication et après j'ai commencé
dans le service informatique puis dans
le Mintel, j'ai créé mon entreprise à
l'époque de de du du début de de
l'internet que finalement j'ai revendu à
à Francecom
chez lequel dans l'entreprise dans
laquelle je suis resté au regard de de
la qualité des postes qui qui m'ont été
proposé et qui fait que que j'y suis
encore.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler certes entre
autres d'intelligence artificielle. On
va parler euh de souveraineté, on va
parler de data, de pipe, on va parler de
d'attaque informationnelle, on va parler
de d'attaque de puissance étrangère et
euh qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir faire et
pour pouvoir avoir euh une souveraineté
correcte. On commence par l'intelligence
artificielle. Sébastien,
on peut on peut commencer par
l'intelligence artificielle. Euh je
crois que bah déjà il faut casser une
première mythologie euh intelligence
terricielle, c'est un glissement
sémantique euh de l'anglais artificial
intelligence euh dont la signification
veut dire renseignement artificiel comme
on dit les intelligent services.
Donc on a projeté sur l'intelligence
l'idée l'imaginaire d'une sorte de
double numérique que nous aurions que
nous pourrions construire. Euh et donc
évidemment euh ça ça a alimenté beaucoup
de fantasme et ça a continu simple cette
simple logique sémantique à alimenter
euh beaucoup de fantasmes. Ça c'est le
premier myth qui vaut casser. Le deuxème
mythe qu'il faut casser, c'est que euh
l'air du numérique a commencé il y a 100
ans. Euh à Allen Turing en est peut-être
le le le premier
poseur de pierre. Et euh cette ère
numérique, elle a commencé il y a 100
ans et elle n'a cessé de progresser. Euh
elle a progressé avec des ordinateurs
qui ont permis de faire la bombe
atomique, avec des ordinateurs qui ont
permis euh de gérer les comptes
bancaires avec d'ordinateurs qui se sont
installés dans les bureaux et qui ont
permis au au secrétariat d'être
totalement transformé avec un internet
qui est arrivé et qui a bouleversé notre
rapport au monde. Et puis aujourd'hui
effectivement le le la bulle médiatique
du moment c'est l'intelligence
artificielle générative. Alors qu'en
réalité l' arel c'est quoi ? C'est des
algorithmes d'un côté, de l'autre côté
c'est des datas. Et en réalité, ces
algorithmes et ces datas ont de tout
temps existé. Euh simplement leur
puissance euh s'est amélioré au fil de
la des infrastructures, du matériel de
disposition, du nombre de données euh de
la quantité de de flux numérique qui
circule. Donc voilà. Donc ce n'est qu'un
un un un é une époque un peu
particulière sans doute que nous vivons
actuellement mais on disait ça il y a 25
ans de l'internet. C'est sans doute pas
la dernière de la révolution du
numérique. Et ce cette cette époque du
numérique a commencé il y a 100 ans.
Elle va continuer sans doute encore de
nombreuses années.
Je voudrais que vous me parliez de la
surveillance émotionnelle.
Ce qui est peut-être le plus
interpellant, c'est
la fulltitude de données. Alors, moi,
j'avais l'habitude de dire
à l'apparition des réseaux sociaux il y
a presque 20 ans et j'ai j'ai travaillé
sur sur des projets pour la vénérable
maison qui qui m'emploie. Euh j'avais
dit euh nous mourrons tous
euh avec euh enfin tous les enfants qui
naissent maintenant hein euh avec les
les réseaux sociaux euh mourront tous
avec une clé USB qu'on mettra dans le
cercueil et sur leur clé USB il y aura
la totalité de leur vie minute après
minute.
Vous savez que ça se fait déjà.
Oui. Oui. Mais dire ça il y a 20 ans ou
15 ans, c'était c'est c'était
iconoclast. C'est l'idée de dire on
mettra une clé USB et en fait on saura
tout minute après minute de la vie de
votre enfant. Ça ça a perturbé quand
même un peu tout le monde et je crois
que malheureusement c'est c'est une
réité et ce n'est même plus la vie entre
guillemets toutes les minutes mais c'est
la vie de toutes les secondes. C'estàd
que à chaque seconde aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des outils numériques qui
nous entourent fait que l'individu sauf
acte volontaire de sa part sans s'en
rendre compte et en permanence
surveiller et et donc des données sont
produites sur lui que ça soit bah si
vous avez votre téléphone sur vous sur
la santé, le nombre de pas, la
localisation que ce soit l'activité donc
physique que ce soit l'activité
éventuellement d'utilisation d'usage et
cetera et cetera. Et là-dedans,
évidemment, il y a des dimensions qui
qui manquent qui peuvent manqu forcément
qui ne manque pas de nous interpeller,
c'est la question de de l'être.
C'est-à-dire que bon bah quand on agit
il y a il y a euh il y a comme on dirait
zite euh c'estàd le temps et l'être euh
et donc évidemment bien sûr on mesure
les les actes, on enregistre les actes
qu'on fait mais il y a aussi l'être et
et aujourd'hui en fait les données qu'on
qu'on collecte, les données qu'on
enregistre permettent en fait d'aller à
l'intérieur de vous-même, c'est-à-dire
la façon dont vous parlez, la façon dont
vont vous exprimer
les éléments
d'information physiologique sur votre
situation
personnelle en fait permettent de savoir
et de et trahissent entre guillemets ou
traduisent
votre situation émotionnelle. Donc on
est en capacité de de dire et de déceler
au travers de votre voix, de votre
visage.
Si vous avez dormi correctement la nuit
précédente, si vous êtes malade, si vous
n'êtes pas malade, euh si vous avez un
des éléments de fatigue, votre
corpulence est analysée, donc on sait si
vous avez maigri et cetera. Évidemment,
cette question émotionnelle et la façon
dont vous parlez permet de traduire la
situation, une éventuelle situation de
stress. Euh et ce qui est de plus en
plus inquiétant, c'est que au regard du
nombre de données qui s'accumulent, on
arrive à à définir des patterns, c'estàd
des des formats de de des schémas des
des schémas euh qui permettent de de
savoir la nature des stress, euh qui
permettent de connaître la nature de vos
préoccupations euh et qui en fait relève
de ce que nous appelons le nom dit entre
nous, c'est-à-dire la question de la
question du nom dit, on a toujours
parler des relations verbales et puis
des et puis de dans le nom dit, mais
aujourd'hui en fait la machine est
capable de détecter au-delà de ce que
l'être humain est capable d'identifier
le nom dit, c'est-à-dire les émotions,
de comprendre et de savoir qui on est.
En terme de prédictif,
maintenant qu'on a fait l'état de l'art
où la on est capable de monitorer
quelqu'un selon sa midriase oculaire,
selon son taux de sudation, selon si il
a des mouvements à contrôler des jambes
ou si tous comme mon réalisateur,
on est on est capable de le le spotter
grâce à de la vidéosurveillance, grâce à
des caméras d'une façon qui ont la
possibilité de se connecter
instantanément sur sur la montre
connectée, son téléphone, son
historicité, son nombre de contacts, si
ses contacts soient à gauche, à droite,
s'ils sont bouddhistes, pas bouddhistes,
cat
son historicité de de par an. En terme
de prédictif, qu'est-ce que ça peut
projeter sur notre société ? Vous
parliez de l'être, moi je vais vous
parler d'âme et je vais vous parler de
ce que ça peut induire sur nos sociétés.
D'une part, on peut déjà s'intéresser
aux aspects positifs.
C'est
peut-être positif. Oui, mais je dis on
va commencer par les aspects positifs et
puis ensuite on va continuer par les
aspects négatifs.
Dans les aspects positif,
la un des principaux enjeux sur lesquels
il y a beaucoup de travaux, il y a
beaucoup d'investissement, c'est la
question de la santé. euh la la
prédictibilité
des maladies qu'on est susceptible de
développer, l'anticipation fait que on
arrive aujourd'hui à détecter des
maladies
qu'on narrive pas forcément à identifier
spontanément parce que les symptômes
sont pas suffisamment apparents.
On peut aussi détecter des maladies qui
ont des probabilités fortes de se
développer sans forcément se développer
parce que la prédictibilité ce n'est pas
la détermination de de l'avenir hein,
c'est juste un un référentiel
statistique. Et donc et donc ça, on va
dire sur la santé, ça peut présenter un
avantage
et à la fois
pour les assureurs et les banquiers,
à la fois d'un point de vue économique,
à la fois pour les individus pour qu'ils
vivent à la fois dans le meilleur
condition, de façon plus confortable et
et et et le cas échéant plus longtemps
si on considère que la durée de vie est
un élément important du d'une vie.
Les autres aspects évidemment qui sont
beaucoup plus inquiétants et qui peuvent
et qui peuvent nous interroger, c'est
que comme toute technologie euh euh il y
a deux pièces, il y a deux phases dans
une pièce. Et euh et donc évidemment de
l'autre côté euh à partir du moment où
vous avez une capacité euh
d'interprétation, d'analyse, de réaction
d'un individu euh
sur ses émotions, euh quand vous lui
projetez une image, euh quand vous lui
envoyez de la musique dans les oreilles,
euh quand vous le mettez dans un
environnement olfactif, euh si vous êtes
en capacité de déterminer les réactions
que ça produit chez lui, ça veut dire
que derrière, vous ouvrez la porte à des
formes de manipulation. Et donc
évidemment une des interrogations et
c'est aussi un peu ce qui a présidé à
tous les scandales ou toutes les ou
toutes les dénonciations qui ont été
faites sur la question des réseaux
sociaux. C'est-à-dire que l'analyse d'un
nombre de données ne serait-ce que
factuelle, hein, indépendamment, on va
dire, de de de du comportement de
l'individu en tant que tel, euh
permettait en fait de diffuser des
messages sur lesquels on allait arriver
à l'écrocher sur 80 % de ce qui
correspondait
à, on va dire, son son centre d'intérêt
ou en tous les cas sa position
traditionnelle. Et puis en fait, on
allait faire passer des messages pour 20
% qui étaient de nature à le faire
changer ou faire évoluer son opinion ou
exagérer, amplifier ou au contraire
amortir son son opinion.
Il y a pas une affaire comme ça, c'est
Cambridge Analytica.
Alors, il y en a, il y a eu
effectivement Cambridge Analytica qui
qui a impliqué Facebook, mais c'est tous
les jours la même chose et ne prenons
simplement que le moteur Google. le
moteur Google ou
un autre hein. Mais ne prenons n'importe
quel n'importe quel outil sur le de de
moteur de recherche. Vous savez très
bien que les recherches ne sont pas ne
sont pas neutres et elles sont
algorithmiquement calculées non pas du
tout pour vous donner satisfaction mais
pour vous inciter à cliquer sur les
liens publicitaires puisque l'objectif
c'est la maximisation
du du taux de clic sur les propositions
qui qui vous sont faites. Donc on voit
bien que plus on accumule de données,
plus on est capable d'identifier
des schémas
dont on est capable de de reproduire
qu'on est capable de reproduire et donc
à partir d'un échantillon
important, on est capable de d'obtenir
des résultats sur sur des masses qui
derrière vont avoir un bénéfice. Si
c'est un bénéfice économique, tant
mieux. Si c'est un bénéfice idéologique,
ça peut être dangereux pour nos
démocraties.
Si on militarise ça, ça donne quoi ? On
fait une expérience français, vous et
moi. Si je dois militariser
la capacité à influencer les masses, ça
pourrait prendre quelle forme ? Par
exemple, si j'empoisonne quelques
données à gauche, si je délivre quelques
données à droite, si je modifie le pipe
de données qui entraîne X intelligence
artificielle, qu'est-ce que ça peut
donner si on se retrouve avec un pouvoir
qui est soumis à des pressions
économiques, des pressions
environnementales,
des pressions sociales
ou des ingérences étrangères ?
Le monde n'a pas changé.
Le monde n'a pas changé et le numérique
n'a pas changé. notre rapport au monde
et l'humain
n'a n'a n'a fait qu'utiliser le
numérique euh pour euh déployer euh la
même intelligence
qu'il avait dans des processus de
manipulation, dans des processus
de de d'altération de de la vérité,
l'affaire des poisons. euh il y a
quelques années sous sous les les on va
dire sous sous les régimes des des
royautés, l'affaire du collier de la
reine quelques années après, la vérité
était pas là. Pour autant, la rumeur, la
propagande, les croquis, les
caricatures, tout ça contribuait à
manipuler l'opinion pour que l'opinion
se retourne contre la courtisane, contre
Marie-Antoinette, contre
la royauté et donc amplifier une
dynamique
qui se voulait révolutionnaire et qui au
final a abouti euh à la Révolution
française. que les processus que qu'on
avait autrefois se sont simplement
transposés dans un univers numérique
avec des mécaniques certes plus
sophistiquées, certes plus
technique mais
pénétrant et sous stéroïde.
Oui. Alors pénétrant pénétrant on a
brûlé les sorcières de Salem sur Dondi.
Euh donc on voit bien que on voit bien
que la vérité était pas là. Donc oui,
pénétrant et et peut-être et peut-être
ce qui avec une densité d'information
extrêmement soutenu, c'està-dire que le
nombre de de de d'altération de la
vérité, de transformation,
d'exagération, de détournement aussi de
de de l'intérêt de l'opinion par la
création de du nouveau scandale, mais
pas besoin d'attendre la génération
d'aujourd'hui pour avoir Coline Powell
agitant
à l'ONU.
un flacon en disant "Regardez les armes
de destruction massif de l'Irak, c'est
de l'entraxe et je vous le dis devant
une assemblée, c'était il y a 25 ans et
au final c'est c'était totalement erroné
et il l'a fait devant toutes les
télévisions du monde. Donc pas besoin
d'attendre ni l'internet, ni le
développement du numérique
d'aujourd'hui, ni les moteurs de
recherche, ni l'intelligence
artificielle. euh ces manipulations ont
toujours existé, elles continueront
d'exister et euh et c'est le c'est la
nature la triste nature de de l'être
humain et et de et de l'exercice du
pouvoir euh à bon ou à mauvaise ession.
Quand on voit des boîtes du numérique
frayé, fricoté avec le pouvoir
politique, le pouvoir militaire, le
pouvoir qui est censé faire de
l'intelligence, du renseignement,
quand on voit les facteurs contraignants
autour de nos sociétés, est-ce que pour
notre démocratie c'est un problème ?
Je crois que alors moi j'ai à la fois
bon j'ai j'ai eu la chance de de d'avoir
un papa surveillé par le service de
renseignement comme du lait sur le feu.
Papa, il avait un copain qui était sur
l'île Saint-Louis ou pas du tout ? Déjà,
moi pour la pour la pour pour l'anecdote
hein, j'ai été surveillé sans doute mais
je pense en tous les cas pour pour
protéger mes parents hein. J'ai été sans
doute surveillé parce que mon père était
interdit de voyage dans les pays de
l'Est
jusqu'à jusqu'à la chute du mur de
Berlin. Donc forcément de fait moi je
l'ai appris beaucoup plus tard, je l'ai
compris beaucoup plus tard et donc et
donc évidemment cette question était
importante puisque j'imagine bien que un
enlèvement pouvait conduire à des
pressions et que c'est vrai que dans les
archives qu'on qu'on trouve évidemment
évidemment il y avait objet. Mais euh
mais au-delà de ça euh mais au-delà de
ça, j'ai eu aussi la chance dans les
dans les dans le dans l'activité que
j'ai exercé chez Orange en tant que
directeur du développement international
de voir une partie du monde. À la fois,
j'étais à l'initiative d'un contrecadre
entre la France et et enfin en tous les
cas Orange Marine et et Cuba pour poser
un câble internet entre Cuba et et la
Martinique hein. qui euh me vaut
aujourd'hui sans doute le plaisir
d'avoir un visa américain et de ne pas
avoir l'estat. Alors, c'est très
antageux parce que je n'ai pas au moins
à justifier euh de mes années des années
que je dois passer sur que j'ai passé
sur Facebook et donner la liste de tous
les gens à qui j'ai envoyé des mails.
Euh puisque j'ai un visa, j'ai pas les
stars. Mais mais je mais voilà parce que
le département d'État m'a écrit très
mais l'ambassade m'a écrit très que le
département d'État a examiné mon dossier
pour savoir si j'avais le droit à visa.
Donc donc on voit bien évidemment on
imagine qu'on peut le reconstituer mais
on peut protéger ses enfants, il faut
protéger ses enfants et donc il y a un
nombre de choses qu'on qu'on peut faire
qui sont assez simples et qui permettent
de faire que sa vie privée soit un peu
moins un peu moins étalé sur la place
publique même si la boîte à fantasme
peut s'alimenter à à ce titre là. Les
relations entre
Qu'est-ce que vous entendez par boîte à
fantasme ? Oh bah euh quand on quand en
fait il manque en fait des informations
sur quelqu'un euh le le le
la logique veut que euh on utilise en
fait ces espaces euh pour broder, pour
inventer, pour créer euh euh de
l'information
et imaginer des relations qui existent
pas forcément mais
et et qui sont en fait et qui évidemment
après interroge sur faut-il en fait tout
dire euh ou au contraire faut-il essayer
de garder un espace privé parce que
immédiatement dès qu'on garde un espace
privé, on est soupçonné de vouloir
dissimuler. Donc c'est aussi un débat
qui doit interroger chacun. Euh faut-il
tout dire au contraire faut-il garder un
espace privé parce que c'est là où la
boîte à fantasme se met en route et et
qu'elle peut vous être préjudiciable.
Mais le politique,
l'économique,
le spirituel ou le religieux ont de tout
temps été mêlé et les stratégies
d'influence des uns et des autres on ont
toujours été là. Donc ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui n'est pas très différent de
ce qu'on a connu dans les siècles passés
sans avoir besoin du numérique pour le
voir. Est-ce que est-ce que Laurent de
Miss 6is était de la politique ou était
ça ou était-ce en fait une famille de
banquier ? Euh la question réponse mon
colonel.
Voilà donc et et c'est bien parce que
l'un était au service de l'autre. Est-ce
que aujourd'hui la dissociation des
fonctions est là ? Est-ce que les
présidents aux États-Unis
sont pauvres ? La réponse est non. Aucun
président des États-Unis depuis un
certain temps n'est pauvre. Donc on voit
bien qu'il y a une relation entre le
poids économique et le la capacité
d'accéder à à des fonctions politiques.
Donc ce qui est pas encore le cas en
Europe, il faut s'en féliciter. Mais
voilà, donc c'est ces relations ont
toujours existé. Le numérique les
amplifie, le numérique donne des des
clés d'échange
et évidemment on appelle ça des renvois
d'ascenseur parce qu'on veut être on
veut être dans le politiquement correct.
C'est assez c'est c'est assez malsin
pour notre démocratie mais ça a toujours
existé.
Quelle était ma question ?
La question c'était la question est-ce
que le est-ce que le danger
militarise tout ça ? Oui. Alors ouais,
la question de la militarisation, c'est
que c'est que alors moi je je reviendrai
peut-être là-dessus. La question de la
militarisation, c'est pour ça que j'ai
parlé du politique. La militarisation,
il faut lire alors F Krig de de
Klauswitz qui dit que finalement la
guerre n'est qu'un instrument de la
politique et donc
prolongement
Oui.
par d'autres moyens.
Voilà. prolongement par d'autres moyens
ou en tous les cas un instrument au
service de la politique. Donc euh la
militarisation euh
n'est que en fait n'est que moyen euh
d'une politique, d'une volonté
politique, d'une stratégie politique,
d'une ambition politique. Et c'est pour
ça que je n'ai pas répondu directement à
la question et si on militariser tout ça
parce que en réalité le militaire obéit
toujours à une dynamique politique et ne
se ne se suffit pas à lui-même et et en
aucun cas on ne fait la guerre pour
faire la guerre.
On revient sur les questions sociétales
quand on a comme comme en France
quelques petits problèmes économiques,
quelques petits problèmes énergétiques,
une population qui va être encore mise à
l'épreuve par des facteurs stressants si
le politique est tenté d'utiliser
l'outil numérique pour censurer,
anticiper des gens qui pourraient
prendre le lead ou des leaders
d'opinion.
Quelles sont les mesures proactives pour
protéger notre société de tout ça ?
Je crois que le plus grand danger le
plus grand danger qui émerge, il émerge
en fait depuis la chute du mur de Berlin
euh c'est-à-dire le 25 décembre, enfin
la chute du mur de Berlin, c'est c'est
évidemment c'est novembre 89. J'étais en
Allemagne à cette époque-là d'ailleurs.
À gauche ou à droite ? Euh mais j'étais
j'étais à Carls Rouer justement. Mais
mais non, je pense que le la ce qu'on a
appel abusivement la chute du mur de
Berlin en réalité, c'est la dislocation
de de l'Union soviétique, donc le 25
décembre 91. Euh ce qui est très
inquiétant c'est la baisse dans le la
baisse de de de dans le PIB du poids de
l'éducation.
Euh et c'est un phénomène où en fait on
peut considérer que euh comme Fukuyama
l'écrit dans dans son dans son premier
ouvrage hein poste poste chute de
l'Union soviétique la fin de l'histoire
euh décrit la fin de l'histoire cette
fameuse fin d'histoire où le capitalisme
triomphant peut désormais apporter la
prospérité, le bonheur comme système
universel et que nous sommes finalement
dans la fin de l'histoire. Euh en
réalité euh nos démocraties ont
abandonné l'idée euh de consacrer des
budgets à l'éducation pour faire
comprendre euh pour expliquer euh pour
informer, pour éduquer, pour élever les
consciences sur le fait que le système
ou les systèmes différents qui existent
sur la planète et qui s'opposaient he
capitalisme contre communisme,
capitalisme très modéré he capitalisme
presque de sociale démocratie
d'un côté et enfin tous les cas très
très très modéré en tous les cas pas
néolibéralisme tel qu'on peut le
connaître aujourd'hui et communisme
étaient deux systèmes qui étaient
antagonistes qui poursuivaient des
ambitions très distinctes mais que
basculer quand même dans un système
communiste avait quand même quelques
inconvénients et donc formait tout le
monde à l'esprit critique. Et donc de ce
fait, on consacrait beaucoup d'argent à
l'éducation pour
monter monter le niveau de conscience.
Forcé de constater que depuis 35 ans,
les budgets consacrés à l'éducation
l'ont cessé de baisser dans le point
économique du PIB. Donc c'est ça le plus
grand danger. Euh et donc face à ça,
évidemment euh le le risque majeur euh
et c'est pour ça que la le risque majeur
c'est que euh le niveau de
compréhension, le le niveau de de de
capacité à d'esprit critique euh face au
danger, face aux perspectives qui
peuvent qui peuvent s'annoncer
peut ne pas plus être au rendez-vous. Et
donc évidemment la première mesure qu'il
faut faire, c'est remonter euh à la fois
pas simplement les budgets parce que
c'est pas aussi une question de budget,
c'est aussi euh une question de de
d'ambition euh d'ambition euh euh
globale, d'ambition politique et de se
dire euh il faut former, il faut
éduquer,
il faut apprendre, il faut faire
apprendre parce que il faut reconsacrer,
il faut que l'ensemble des populations
reconsacre du temps à s'informer, se
cultiver, réapprendre l'histoire pour
comprendre c'est parce que on connaît
son passé qu'on qu'on peut construire
son futur.
On peut éviter de le reproduire.
Ouais. Alors le reproduire, moi je suis
je suis toujours dubitatif sur cette
logique où
l'histoire se répète. Je crois que je
crois que c'est très compliqué de dire
que l'histoire se répète. Je crois que
les les facteurs et c'est tellement
polyfactoriel que qu'il est difficile de
dire que l'histoire se répète et et moi
je j'évite de faire des comparaisons
entre ce qui s'est passé et ce qui se
passera en tous les cas dans les dans
dans les systèmes globaux. Il y a des
événements évidemment qui qui qui se
reproduisent et qui qui entraînent les
mêmes mécaniques, mais j'aivie d'en
faire une généralité parce que je pense
que les facteurs sont sont toujours très
très divers et ne se reproduisent jamais
exactement de la même façon et que les
circonstances l'histoire n'est pas une
science exacte. On définit ce qu'on
appelle les sciences dures et les
sciences molles par la capacité de
reproductibilité.
Euh donc c'està dire que les conditions
de l'expérience doivent être identiques.
C'est le cas pour la physique, c'est le
cas pour c'est le cas pour les
mathématiques, c'est c'est sciences dur,
c'est pas le cas pour l'histoire, c'est
pas le cas pour l'économie. Même si en
fait on peut avoir des des schémas, des
ressemblances, des analogies. Euh la le
la cause et la conséquence euh existe en
en math et en physique. Elles existent
pas en histoire, elles existent pas dans
les sances sociales, même si euh il y a
des tendances, il y a des probabilités.
Mais voilà,
je peux vous demander de reformuler la
la réponse sur la l'éducation et les
risques d'avoir un affaiblissement de
notre système éducatif par rapport à à
toutes les propagandes qui vont pouvoir
sévir sur notre population. Je voudrais
une reformulation plus simple,
plus moins ampoulé et plus fleuri.
Ah oui. Alors
l'éducation alors déjà en fait premier
premier postulat déjà on pourrait dire
que l'éducation appartient aux parents
et que l'enseignement appartient à
l'État. Déjà c'est deux notions qui
peut-être mériteraient d'être d'être
explicite.
Je peux vous couper ? Oui.
Quand on voit le l'État se substituer
aux parents dans l'éducation, ça vous
fait penser à quoi ? Un pouvoir
communiste ?
Non, je crois que c'est je crois que
c'est une c'est une absence de de prise
de conscience de de la nécessité du rôle
de parents dans la transmission des des
principes fondamentaux de la vie en
commun. Donc à ce titre làà il faut
retrouver une société où on retrouve des
valeurs de transmission. Euh après, on
peut avoir des transmissions diverses,
hein, et et et des principes éducatifs
différents. Euh mais il n'en reste pas
moins que l'éducation, c'est les parents
et que l'enseignement euh c'est euh
c'est c'est c'est l'État et c'est un peu
le sens. Pour ça que le mot euh
éducation nationale, le ministère de
l'éducation nationale est peut-être un
peu galvodé. On ferait mieux parler de
du ministère de l'enseignement national
et de laisser l'éducation aux parents et
de re de repositionner les choses dans
cet état. Mais si on veut euh reposer la
question euh de de l'éducation euh et en
tous les cas de l'enseignement, tout
l'enseignement que nous suivisons, il a
deux dimensions. Il a une première
dimension qui est la transmission de
savoir et c'est pour ça que sur la
question par exemple de l'école, il ne
faut pas aller vers la satisfaction de
l'élève, il faut aller vers la
transmission du savoir de la nation.
Donc il faut revenir
faut revenir à euh à à ce fondamental
euh principe euh qui est que l'école
n'est là n'est pas là pour apporter du
bien-être aux élèves. Il est là pour
garantir la transmission des savoirs
d'une nation. Et c'est parce qu'une
nation arrive à transmettre ses savoirs
qu'elle arrive à progresser et à avancer
sur le chemin de la connaissance et
forcément du bien-être de de ces
concitoyens.
Et le la deuxième il est bon puisque ça
c'est c'est la transmission des
connaissances. Le deuxième enjeu c'est
la capacité à être dans une situation de
critique de critique pas forcément
négative mais de critique dans ce qu'on
appelle l'esprit critique. C'est-à-dire
est-ce que ce qu'on m'enseigne
est fondé ? Est-ce que l'analyse que les
professeurs font de l'histoire, n'est-ce
pas finalement l'histoire des vainqueurs
? Est-ce que la lecture qu'on a
d'histoire n'a pas changé avec le temps
? Je prends c ce simple exemple. à la
sortie de la guerre, tous les toutes les
personnes qu'on interrogeait quand on
leur demandait "Mais grâce à qui la
seconde guerre mondiale était gagné ?"
La majorité des Français vous disaient
"Bah l'Union l'Union soviétique."
Aujourd'hui, vous demandez la majorité
des Français ou une petite majorité vous
répond "C'est grâce aux Américains." Euh
donc, on voit bien en fait ce
déplacement. Est-ce que c'est euh euh
les le rouleau compresseur soviétique
qui qui a sacrifié des millions de
soldats en allant vers Berlin qui qui
est le principal responsable ou est-ce
les Américains en faisant un
débarquement certes spectaculaire d'un
point de vue logistique et
organisationnel
même si De Gaulle ne s'y rendait jamais
et en considérait que c'était le
débarquement de Provence qui était le
véritable le véritable débarquement qui
avait libéré la France. Euh est-ce que
c'est ce débarquement-là qui qui est
plus important ? Sans doute aucun des
deux, sans doute un peu des deux, sans
doute beaucoup des deux. Euh mais il
faut pas se dire euh qu'il y a une seule
histoire, il y a plusieurs histoires euh
et donc il faut garder cet esprit
critique. Et donc c'est la vocation de
l'enseignement de transmettre d'un côté
les savoirs, de l'autre côté nous
apprendre à avoir une vue critique sur
euh tout ce que nous vivons, tout ce que
nous percevons, tout ce que nous
entendons, tout ce que nous lisons.
Votre regard sur ce qui se passe en ce
moment, sur l'enseignement, l'éducation,
les médias, l'histoire et enfin nos
politiques. Est-ce que vous avez pas
l'impression de voir à la tête de nos
politiques un président de BDE
complètement immatur ? Est-ce que vous
avez pas l'impression de voir dans nos
journalistes euh des colp porteurs la
plupart du temps d'informations pas
vérifiées ou extrapolé ou influencé par
X puissance et et concernant notre
éducation, une éducation majoritairement
soit sous-dimensionnée,
pas adaptée, qui ne comprend pas les
enjeux.
Ce qui est certain, c'est que
à la fois la globalisation euh la chute
des systèmes et la chute des empires. En
cas la chute d'un des deux empires au
20e siècle d'ailleurs avec l'apparition
d'un nouvel empire qui qui est la Chine
sur le 21e siècle et qui reposera
d'ailleurs des questions sur cet
antagonisme des empires. Puisque à toute
époque, il y a eu en fait la guerre des
empires. le 19e siècle était alimenté
entre l'Empire anglais et et l'empire
français. Le 20e siècle, on l'a vu entre
on l'a vu à différ à différentes
reprises. Il y a eu des empires qui se
sont qui ont émergé puisque à la fin du
du 19e siècle, c'est l'empire allemand
qui est arrivé. C'est pour ça qu'on a eu
la triste guerre de de de 141 mais qui
s'est finalement reprolongé avec 39 45.
Euh donc c'est cette guerre des empires
a a toujours existé.
et euh et donc à créer des des
mécaniques des mécaniques sont
intéressantes à à analyser. Euh ce qui
soutend depuis la révolution
industrielle euh une aenton d'action,
c'est quand même le moteur économique
des des des acteurs. Et donc
aujourd'hui, on a une financiarisation,
une excès de financiérisation alors qui
a pu être ralenti dans les tres
glorieuses et qui a sans doute été
ralenti dans les tres glorieuses et qui
conduit à ce que il y a une forme de
monétisation
de tout ce qui est de tout ce qui est on
va dire qui est dehors de la production.
Donc euh évidemment euh les médias sont
soumis à des contraintes économiques,
d'où euh euh la captation euh d'une
partie des médias par euh des puissances
financières euh
des partis politiques,
des partis politiques, des puissances
étrangères. Euh on oublie, alors
évidemment la France a peut-être été un
peu protégée, mais enfin per Mordoc
n'avait pas un empire qui s'étendait sur
la simple Australie mais aussi sur
l'Angleterre. Donc on voit bien que
qu'il y avait si ce n'est en parlant
d'ingérence parce que les deux pays sont
deux pays historiquement alliés mais
enfin on voit bien comment un pays avait
la capacité à influencer un autre et
tout ça est paradoxalement très bien
décrit dans les James Bond et dont on
pourrait don on pourrait dire un mot sur
le sur le le caractère tout à fait
fascinant de de la filmographie
hollywoodienne pour décrire les
phénomènes de société qu'on vit. Mais
euh et donc en fait euh oui, je crois
que le le l'argent est devenu euh euh un
élément structurant. Euh euh on dit
toujours que finalement les deux grandes
révolutions de l'humanité euh c'est pas
le feu, c'est pas la roue, les deux
grandes révolutions de l'humanité, ça a
été la dématérialisation
des biens physiques par l'argent et ça a
été la démertérisation des personnes
physiques par la création des personnes
morales. Et ça finalement c'est
peut-être les deux plus grandes
révolutions que l'humanité a connue par
rapport à d'autres d'autres
environnements parce que le feu ou la
roue ne finalement ne sont que des
outils. Mais là on a créé deux concepts
qui ont finalement structuré et organisé
nos sociétés et qui investissent de plus
en plus notre espace au fil du temps, au
fil des siècles, au fil des années. La
personnalité morale est omniprésente
dans les agissements de l'économie.
La personnalité la personnalité morale
est est omniprésente. On parle des fonds
de pension, on parle des des de ces
acteurs ou des masses financières
absolument colossales circulent. et de
l'autre côté et qui et de l'autre côté
en fait on a dématériisé les biens, on a
supprimé le troc, on est passé sur
finalement une sorte de de monnaie
d'échange hein euh qui qui n'a pas de
qui n'a pas de substance mais qui a été
une dématérialisation et qui aujourd'hui
devient le principe auquel tout le monde
se réfère. Donc l'argent d'un côté et la
personnalité morale sont les deux
fondements et sans doute les deux plus
grandes créations de l'humanité. Euh à
partir du moment où
avec la religion,
la religion, elle a elle a sans doute
elle a sans doute été toujours une
interrogation de de de l'humanité
par rapport à son propre destin et à sa
propre finalité. Euh aujourd'hui, je ne
suis pas sûr que nous soyons pas dans
une très forte régression euh quelle que
soi d'ailleurs les religions euh du euh
de la croyance. C'est-à-dire que euh la
la déconfessionnalisation des sociétés
n'a jamais été aussi importante dans le
monde entier. Évidemment, on a des
dynamiques géographiques
euh qui sont un peu différentes sur
certaines religions plutôt que d'autres
et cetera bien sûr.
Globalement Globalement je pense que
l'homme est arrivé à un niveau euh est
arrivé à un niveau de de connaissance
qui qui l'amène à s'interroger sur son
propre destin, son propre devenir, sa
propre substance et et donc la la
religion est en très forte régression et
n'a pas été une invention, c'est-à-dire
qu'elle a été une réponse
elle a été une réponse à une angoisse
permanente
pour survivre parce que ce qu'on oublie
aussi beaucoup, c'est que et là
évidemment On change un petit peu la la
question et l'angle de la question que
vous me posez puisque vous me posez la
question la religion. Mais nous ne
sommes des survivants que parce que nous
avons développé par le processus de
sélection naturelle une capacité à avoir
à la fois un stress qui nous met en
éveil. D'où d'où le d'où le le le le
sentiment que que la caféine que nous
buvons tous les matins nous permet
d'être plus actif au bureau. En fait,
pas du tout. nous met en situation de
stress euh parce que nous étions
terrorisés dans la savane d'être dévoré
par les lions qui étaient tout autour
euh et de la même
par ses petits copains,
pardon,
par ses petits copains.
Oui, après on avait des tas d'autres
d'aut d'autres d'autres gentils animaux
mais en tous les cas c'était la notion
de stress qui faisait qu'on survive.
Ceux qui étaient les plus stressés
étaient ceux qui survivaient le plus.
Euh et donc évidemment à un moment euh
la question s'est posée, c'est euh
vous connaissez la la spécialité pour
étudier ça ?
Non non,
l'épigénétique.
Ah oui oui, l'épigénétique. Euh ouais,
parce que moi je plus je connais mais
euh et de l'autre côté la question c'est
bon très bien, je survis mais je survis
pour aller où ? Et donc évidemment la
question de la religion en fait c'est
est apparue parce que bah une fois que
j'ai répondu à à la logique de
l'instinct de survie et que je comprends
que je suis je pense donc je suis bah
forcément la question c'est
tout ça pourquoi et tout ça pourquoi ?
Donc évidemment la la religion c'est
c'est et tout ce que je ne comprends pas
étais dans dans cet univers religieux
et qui s'est développelé. C'est pour ça
que la religion n'est pas une invention,
elle est une réponse. En revanche,
l'argent est une création humaine et la
personnalité morale est une création
humaine. Euh donc et à partir du moment
où on a créé ces ces deux outils,
il se trouve qu'à un moment une partie
de de de la pensée philosophique a
commencé à à rejeter finalement cette
idée de l'argent de donc évidemment de
tout ce que ça engendre de la propriété
de la de la de la valorisation de de cet
argent et qui a été le système
communiste. Et donc et et donc à partir
du moment où le système communiste a
chuté, on s'est retrouvé avec un argent
triomphant
qui est le moteur et qui reste le moteur
de beaucoup d'actions, de beaucoup
d'acteurs
pour le pour pas certainement pas pour
le meilleur parce que je pense pas que
l'argent soit la valeur principale
auquelle on doit chacun se référer pour
vivre.
Je peux vous poser une question
personnelle ?
Vous avez un ami imaginaire ? Vous
croyez dans quelque chose ?
Bonne question. Est-ce que je suis
uniliste ou pas ? Est-ce qu'il y a une
finalité dans dans ce qu'on fait ? C'est
c'est une question que je me pose
souvent tous les matins. Euh
la question qui est certaine, c'est que
nous sommes là. Euh
est-ce que vous en êtes bien sûr ?
Oui. Oui. Moi, je je reste persuadé que
que nous nous sommes là. En tous les
cas, nous avons l'impression d'être là.
Donc par le fait que si nous en avons
l'impression, c'est que nous nous sommes
là. Alors peut-être pas sous la forme
que que que nous voudrions, mais mais en
tous les cas, on est on est là. Euh pour
autant, on est là qu'un temps.
Euh notre niveau de conscience est une
conscience temporellement très réduite à
l'échelle de ce qu'on peut comprendre de
de l'univers dans lequel on vit.
Euh et donc la question c'est croire euh
croire dans le fait que oui, il existe
quelque chose. Après euh euh on pourrait
euh on pourrait aussi euh dans des
logiques d'inspiration mathématique,
hein, les principes d'incertitude de
Guel qui sont des principes
mathématiques où il est démontré que
nous ne pouvons pas savoir
si une proposition est vraie ou est
fausse euh se se pose à nous,
c'est-à-dire à la question "Dieu
existe-t-il ou Dieu n'existe pas Nous ne
serons pas capablees de répondre. Nous
ne sommes pas capables de répondre et
nous ne serons sans doute jamais en
capacité d'y répondre. Et je crois au
fait que nous ne sommes pas en capacité
de répondre à la question "Dieu
existe-t-il ?"
Vous avez lu Nietzsche ?
Oui, je l'ai lu Nietzsche pas forcément
pas forcément. Il y a il y a a il y a
peu de temps. Donc j'en ai un souvenir
plus ou moins
plus ou moins parfois évanissant. J'en
ai retenu quelques principes, pas les
plus euh pas les plus favorables. La
main euh
celui qui euh celui qu'on nourrit enfin
ce celui qui est nourri mort la main de
ce qui l'a nourri. Donc évidemment,
c'est c'est pas forcément des principes
très très très positifs. Euh notamment
les les principes qui sont développés
hein sur le rapport d'inégalité dans le
don euh et comment en fait l'individu et
une partie des individus n'arrive pas à
accepter
l'aide de l'autre. C'est-à-dire que
finalement, et c'est peut-être le plus
euh le plus terrifiant dans dans l'être
humain, c'est que quand vous faites un
cadeau à quelqu'un, si ce cadeau crée un
déséquilibre euh que la personne à qui
vous faites ce cadeau euh ne supporte
pas, euh il va vous en vouloir plutôt
que vous en remercier. et Niet écrit ça
de façon beaucoup plus élégante que ce
que je vous dis dans dans des pages
entières pour pour vous expliquer que
voilà, on mort la main de celui qui vous
nourrit et que c'est malheureusement une
pratique extrêmement fréquente. C'estàd
que la rupture d'égalité dans la
relation interpersonnelle
provient souvent du fait que quand vous
aidez quelqu'un et ben finalement au
lieu de vous en remercier
ne supporte pas cette inégalité, ne
supporte pas en fait cette cette dette
morale qui n'est pas une dette
financière qui n'est une dette morale et
et finalement préfère être agressif avec
vous ou avoir un comportement
on va dire désagréable dans la meilleur
des
voir
vo voir voir agressif à votre endroit et
c'est ce qui peut-être dans l'être
humain me chagrine le plus et c'est de
voir que tout ça a été écrit et et
malheureusement se réaliste trop
souvent.
On a parlé du pouvoir de l'argent, on a
parlé de concentration des pouvoirs, on
a parlé de quelques pulsions
animal. Maintenant, avec le numérique,
quand on voit une upper class
concentrée, la data, l'analyse de la
data, la robotique,
qu'on voit des idées de transfert de
conscience dans la machine ou vice-versa
peut-être atteindre l'immortalité.
Qu'est-ce que ça peut générer sur nos
pauvres petites sociétés de petits
macaques qui nous que nous sommes à
continuer à nous taper avec des petits
coup de bâton ?
Alors, l'immortalité,
ça renvoie à deux idées. Euh la
première, c'est nous ne sommes pas
immortels
en tant qu'individu et nous ne le serons
jamais. Alors, je vous coupe, je suis
désolé.
On on je voulais pas organiser le cette
interview dans ce sens là, mais on va la
continuer parce que je trouve ça très
intéressant. Et alors on continue.
C'est vous qui posez la question.
C'est moi rép c'est oui comme dirait
George March Cabache c'est vous qui
faites les questions, c'est moi qui fait
les réponses.
George Marchet ici
euh George Marchet pour pour nos
spectateurs. Qui est George Marchet ?
Qui est George Marchet ici ? Vous ou moi
? Euh c'est la ça là là on rentre dans
un problème philosophique qui est le
maître et qui est l'esclave.
Est-ce que vous voulez être le maître ?
Je ne répondrai pas à cette question. Je
vous invite à à lire les textes qui
l'expliquent parfaitement. Euh mais euh
sur la question de l'immortalité euh si
on considère que l'individu tel que nous
sommes euh je dirais que il faut lire
euh ce que je disais tout à l'heure,
c'est il faut lire un c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait nous ne sommes à la fois
pas le même la seconde d'après que la
seconde précédente. Donc en réalité
qu'est-ce que l'immortalité ? La
première dimension, c'est
nous ne sommes pas figés, nous sommes un
individu, nous sommes des individus en
évolution. Et donc finalement, qu'est-ce
que l'immortalité ? Puisque nous ne
sommes pas à l'âge de 20 ans, le même
que nous sommes à l'âge de 40 ans. Donc
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ce concept
d'immortalité ? Si l'immortalité est un
concept physiologique qui consiste à
dire je n'ai j'ai des cellules
assemblées les unes avec les autres dont
on sait progressivement
enfin au fil du temps que finalement on
va nous en remplacer une bonne partie
par des méthodes diverses et variées.
La question de l'unicité identitaire
d'un point de vue biologique va
s'altérer. Euh peut-être que ça va
toucher des capacités des capacités
cognitives. Donc si on suppose que c'est
l'unicité biologique qui constitue le
concept d'immortalité,
je pense qu'il va être rapidement très
altéré puisque entre le changement de de
ce que la transformation de l'individu
et son altération physiologique,
ça va être compliqué de dire qu'un
individu qui a qui qui naît et un
individu qui a 1000 ans et est le même
et que là-dedans, on a qualifié ça
d'immortalité.
Mais effectivement, ça peut donner
l'impression qu'à un temps donné euh la
possibilité qu'on ait encore du temps
devant soi euh donne le sentiment que
l'instant présent se projette dans le
dans le futur comme étant l'instant
existant et donc et donne ce concept
d'immortalité. Mais le changement le
changement en fait supprime le concept
d'immortalité par lui-même.
Le deuxième aspect, c'est si on prend la
l'aspect biologique,
nous serons tous mortels parce que il
sera très difficile ou en tous les cas
qu'on on vivra dans des univers
décorrélés, mais il sera très difficile
de protéger notre intégrité physique de
façon permanente. C'est-à-dire que
l'intégrité physique fera qu'on sera
toujours susceptible d'être victime d'un
accident d'avion, d'être renversé dans
dans dans la rue et cetera. Et donc la
la notion d'immortalité,
on va dire, on va dire la la capacité de
de vivre longtemps peut évidemment
arriver. Dans ce cas-là, ça veut dire
quoi ? C'estàd que finalement on va
rentrer chez soi, on va se mettre dans
un caisson et finalement on va être
obligé de tout piloter à partir de son
cerveau sans bouger. Et encore, il
faudra avoir les garanties que la prise
se débranche pas parce que si elle se
débranche, peut-être que on pourrait se
faire électrocuter dans le caisson dans
lequel on se trouve à ce moment-là. Donc
donc l'immortalité n'existera pas. Donc
à partir de ce moment-là, nous sommes
tous mortels. On a un début, on a une
fin, elle sera plus ou moins longue.
Sans doute le rapport de nouveau à
l'argent hein fera que l'argent
prolongera la vie de certains certains
signes de science-fiction. Et la
science-fiction est très inspiratrice
tant d'un point de vue littéraire que
d'un point de vue cinématographique où
on montre que le temps
ça quoi ? Oh bah, il y a il y a il y a
eu quelques films sur ce rapport où on
achète où le la monnaie euh la monnaie
courante n'est plus l'argent et le
temps.
Time Code
par exemple. Euh mais euh mais mais euh
mais il y a il y a plusieurs il y a
plusieurs auteurs de de science-fiction
qui qui ont écrit sur cette notion où
euh les riches vivent longtemps, les
pauvres vivent peu longtemps et
on peut le toujours non ?
Plus ou moins, on a des systèmes de de
répartition de santé qui font que nos
moyennes d'âge sont quand même
aujourd'hui à notre époque moins moins
notre espérance de vie est quand même
moins différenciée que elle ne
Je demande à la communauté de me faire
checker mais je crois qu'un ouvrier vit
20 ans de moins qu'un cadre non ? Alors,
j'ai alors moi, j'ai écrit d'ailleurs un
papier dans le monde une tribune sur euh
euh que faire face à la question des
retraites où je prends les statistiques
de l'INC et il est démontré que quel que
soit l'âge à laquelle on part à la
retraite, euh on meurt 16 à 17 ans
après.
Alors attention, ça ne veut pas dire
l'âge individuel, c'est l'âge d'une
classe. C'estàdire si vous prenez votre
retraite à 100 ans, globalement vous
mourrez à 77 ans ou 76 ans. Je crois que
c'est un peu entre les deux. Si vous
prenez votre si la classe d'âge enfin la
classe qui prend sa retraite à 63 ans,
elle va mourir à 80 ans. Donc c'est
c'est assez assez frappant d'avoir ces
statistiques sur la période des gens qui
partent à la retraite entre 60 et 65
ans. En réalité, on sait que leur
expérence de vie est à peu près
identique d'un point de vue statistique,
hein, pas d'un point de vue individuel.
Donc un point de vue collectif. J'ai
créé un papier dans le monde pour pour
décrire tout ça. Donc donc oui,
évidemment. Et pourquoi on part à la
retraite à son temps ? parce qu'on a une
carrière longue. Si on a une carrière
longue, c'est qu'on a commencé tôt. Si
on a commencé tôt, c'est qu'on a pas
fait d'études. Si on n pas fait
d'études, c'est qu'on a eu des travaux
plus des activités plus pénible et
cetera et cetera. Donc oui, on a bien
sûr toujours cette cette différence. 20
ans me semble largement exagéré, mais en
tous les cas, la différence d'âge, elle
existe et et elle est matérialisée dans
le système de retraite. C'est pour ça
que le choix de 64 ans est un choix
profondément injuste d'un point de vue
social et il fallait choisir un nombre
d'années de travail puisque derrière ça
donnait un nombre d'années de pension et
que pour ceux qui militent pour la
retraite par capitalisation, bah
derrière il y a une rente à à verser et
donc on sait que globalement si on prend
ça quel que soit l'âge à laquelle on
prend sa retraite la moyenne le temps
moyen de de la rente se serait le même
donc ce serait beaucoup plus juste en
tout cas c'est pas ce qu'a choisi le
gouvernement actuel et et c'est
profondément injuste d'un point de vue
social et et et sociétal. Donc la moral
l'immortalité n'existe pas. On on est on
a on a vu cette question.
La question du transfert de nos
personnalités,
la la question du transfert de notre
personnalité
dans des appareils, dans une
reproduction
est un est a été aussi traité hein des
des tas de de d'auteurs de
science-fiction, de nouveaux des films
pour ceux qui regardent un peu la
filmographie, on appelle ça à l'aube du
7e jour du 6e jour hein. Alors
évidemment film grand public pas début
ailleurs un grand succès parce que trop
philosophique
par exemple. Oui. Donc c'est c'est assez
c'est assez frappant de de de voir en
fait on comprend que en fait qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? En fait, on est capable de
reproduire un corps biologique dans
lequel on réinjecte votre mémoire parce
que on est capable de capturer entre
guillemets votre mémoire et la structure
mentale dans laquelle vous avez. et puis
on est capable de la mettre sur un un CD
et puis on vous réinjecte votre CD dans
un nouveau corps neutre que on a fait
qu'on a plongé dans dans un bain dans
dans un bain de de de
de
génération de de de tissus organique. Et
donc évidemment le fantasme qu'on a dans
d'autres dans d'autres livres he c'estd
le transfert de notre pensée, le
transfert de notre cerveau dans
l'humérique pose quand même un véritable
problème. C'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui,
on a un cerveau, on sait globalement pas
comment il fonctionne et à part en faire
une copie et à part en faire une copie,
une photocopie qu'on arrivera peut-être
à faire avec les technologies, je vois
pas très bien comment d'un système
biologique on arrivera à transcrire ça
dans un environnement numérique. Dans
tous les cas, moi je je ne l'imagine
pas, je ne le conçois pas, je l'anticipe
pas et peut-être que je suis en retard
d'ailleurs sur sur ces sujet là. Euh
mais peut-être qu'on sera capable
finalement de de reproduire euh de de
reproduire par un système de photocopie
biologique euh des modèles qui feront
que on aura cerveau. Mais de nouveau,
notre cerveau évolue, notre cerveau
vieillit et donc qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire que que que transférer entre
guillemets son cerveau, ses capacités
alors il faudrait sans doute altérer ses
capacités biologiques pour les rendre
plus performantes et de nouveau ça
renvoie à à des questions de transfert
et finalement est-ce que celui qui
serait ainsi créé serait finalement le
même que celui dont on est parti ? que
la question l'immortalité reste posée.
Est-ce que l'être ainsiement créé qui
serait une photocopie euh serait serait
serait l'individu lui-même ? Je pense
que toutes ces questions philosophiques,
elles sont elles interpellent, elles
interpellent sur qui nous sommes, où
nous sommes, où nous allons, pourquoi on
fait tout ça.
Oui, c'est des vraies questions
existentielles sur lesquelles il permet
de s'interroger. Euh beaucoup de
fantasmes, beaucoup de réalités aussi
parce que je pense qu'on met beaucoup
d'argent sur ces sujets-là. En tous les
cas, les milliardaires de la silicone
sont très clairement obsédés par cette
question-là. Euh
pourquoi ?
Bah
parce que d'une part euh parce que d'une
part
faut du temps pour claquer son fric.
Non, parce que parce que je pense que
c'est le c'est le c'est le c'est le
c'est la dernière frontière. C'est la
dernière frontière. C'est-à-dire que à
partir du moment où vous avez tout ce
qui est consommable
en terme de de de produit de service
Oui. de plaisir
de pouvoir. Oui. Le pouvoir est encore
une notion très relative.
Vous avez suivi l'affaire ?
Oui oui malheureusement. Oui
malheureusement. J'ai malheureusement
suivi l'affaire. Oui.
Fais pas penser à spectre.
Je je sais pas, je je pense que je pense
que le le euh je pense que le que que
certains individus ont la capacité à
séduire plus que d'autres parce que ça
fait partie de de de
leur capacité intrinsèque. Travailler ou
pas travailler en partie à qui iné à qui
et et finalement arrive à avoir des des
des sphères d'influence.
Un peu comme tous nos hommes politiques,
un peu comme les businessman qui
réussissent, ils ont une capacité à
convaincre, ils ont une capacité à
séduire, ils ont une capacité à
anticiper un de de de comportement de de
phénomènes et de de gérer de de gérer
les opportunités. Euh donc
oui, c'est certain. Mais pour en revenir
à la question de la dernière frontière,
c'est une fois que vous êtes en capacité
euh d'avoir accès à tout, euh vous ne
mangez euh que trois fois par jour. Bon,
certes, vous pouvez manger plus mais euh
ou moins
pardon
ou moins euh enfin on va dire
petit-déjeuner déjeuner dîner euh que
vous pouvez voyager d'un bout à l'autre
du monde parce que vous avez votre avion
privé, parce que si vous avez envie de
de regarder le le soleil se lever euh
sur les plages de Bali et quelques
heures après finalement euh traverser
euh traverser
le le la vallée de la mort, vous pouvez
le faire à pied. Vous avez envie de vous
balader, vous pouvez le faire à quelques
heures après. Donc à partir du moment où
vous avez accès à tout, qu'est-ce qui
vous reste ? le temps pour tout faire,
le temps pour aller jusqu'au bout des
choses que que vous avez pas envie de
faire, le temps d'avoir d'en avoir
encore plus cette accumulation dans
lequel
voilà, donc c'est une sorte d'espèce
d'instinct de survie, une espèce de de
de volonté de de de de d'accumuler, de
de pouvoir profiter peut-être de toutes
les choses qu'on qu'on peut pas faire.
Oui, c'est c'est un rêve, c'est un rêve
fou qu'il poursuivent. Euh oui, le le
l'humanité de depuis un certain temps
cherche à vivre éternellement. Elle elle
l'espère, elle l'espère au travers de la
la religion. Elle l'a espéré au travers
de la religion. Aujourd'hui, elle
l'espère au travers du numérique.
C'est une nouvelle religion.
Si ce n'est une nouvelle religion, c'est
clairement en tous les cas le le la
silicone vallée nous apprend que
ce sont des projets politiques. Ce sont
des projets politiques pour la société
de demain. Quand
c'est quoi la société de demain ?
Euh le le le Eric Schmid de Google
disait quand il lançait son moteur de
recherche il y a à peu près 20 ans, "On
ne pourra plus rien cacher demain,
Google sera tout.
on en est pas loin. Euh donc c'est un
projet de transparence absolue, d'une
société transparente absolue. C'était
son projet politique et c'était
l'ambition qui qu'il
poursuivait ou en tous les cas c'était
c'était la logique de l'ambition de de
l'outil en tous les cas qui qui qui le
développait. Donc chacun poursuit un un
projet politique de nature différente.
Certains évidemment de contrôler les
télécommunications,
les autres d'influer évidemment sur les
état,
les les autres de de de
formater la la société d'une certaine
façon le et donc chacun poursuit en le
disant plus ou moins de façon claire un
projet politique et et et tous
d'ailleurs ont envisagé de de se
présenter à la présence de de à la
présidence des des États-Unis. Certains
l'ont dit, d'autres le disent moins fort
parce que oui, parce qu'ils ont des
ambitions à la fois pour eux-mêmes et
pour leur pays.
On passe l'aspect philosophique et on va
revenir sur les câbles, sur la
géopolitique des câbles, sur comment se
retrouve la France au milieu de tout ça,
quels sont encore les les effets de
levier de la France pour essayer de
récupérer sa voie à l'échelle
internationale ? Donc les câbles en
France, il y a beaucoup de câbles. Du
moins, il y a beaucoup de départs de
câbles. Il y a beaucoup de départs de
câbles qui vont vers l'Afrique, qui vont
vers les États-Unis. Est-ce que on
utilise ça correctement en tant que
France pour avoir des leviers,
résister et peut-être se défendre et
influencer ?
Je crois que c'est très intéressant
l'histoire des câbles,
sans déconner.
Euh mais il faut pas l'apprendre
aujourd'hui. Euh il faut l'apprendre au
19e siècle.
Euh il faut commencer au 19e siècle. À
quoi servent les câbles ? Évidemment on
téléphonait pas au 10e siècle he même si
le téléphone était inventé, les câbles
ne le permettaient pas. On on faisait du
du télégramme. Euh et
tgra
télégram
le le télégraphe le le télégraphe. En
tout cas euh euh on était dans un mode,
c'était le morse he qui était utilisé
euh pour
communiquer entre les pour communiquer
entre les
entre
comment dire les colonies et les pays et
les les pays européens. Donc les câbles
et le la structure des câbles est assez
fascinante. Si si vous regardez une
carte des câbles au 19e siècle, vous
allez voir en fait les câbles sont posés
pour qu'un pays euh puisse en fait
communiquer avec ses ses colonies.
Donc c'était euh une façon de
communiquer qui était quand même un tout
petit peu plus rapide que d'envoyer des
bateaux pour envoyer les ordres parce
qu'on a vu ce que ça a donné. Euh ça a
donné que globalement avec l'invasion de
de de l'Espagne par Napoléon et le
renversement de la royauté, ça a mis une
pagaille noire parce que le temps que
l'information arrive en Amérique du Sud,
il y en a qui ont fait beaucoup d'argent
grâce à ça.
Ouais, voilà. Bien sûr, mais mais en
tous les cas, il y avait pas de câble à
cette époque. L'information arrivait, on
savait plus de quel côté était le roi.
les colonies ont commencé à bouger et
finalement euh l'Amérique latine a a
sauté en 1820 euh parce que finalement
l'information arrivait dans des délais
qui étaient totalement totalement
importants et évidemment était
totalement déstructurant pour arriver à
organiser euh organiser le le la gestion
de de de la de cette colonie. Euh mais
au-delà de ça, donc on a d'abord eu ces
câbles qui ont été euh des câbles
d'empir coloniaux. Et puis ensuite, on a
une deuxième époque qui est assez
intéressante qui qui est arrivée et qui
a été, on va dire, à l'époque des des
câbles de euh
de la mondialisation d'une d'un début de
mondialisation heureuse sous sous
l'égide d'un peu de l'ONU dans cet
esprit. Tous les pays communiquent les
uns avec les autres. Donc un centre de
projet où euh on relie tous les pays les
uns aux autres et on et on organise et
on organise des des connexions des pays
les uns avec les autres. Ça c'est la
deuxième période qui qui arrive. Et puis
ensuite, on a une troisème période qui
arrive qui est une période intéressante
qui est la période où en fait on tombe
là on n'est plus dans le champ donc
d'abord on a été dans un champ presque à
la fois politique et économique mais
d'abord politique parce que ça été
soutenu par une politique très offensive
des États de contrôler leur colonie. On
est arrivé dans un deuxième projet qui é
un projet politique hein de de
mondialisation finalement heureuse. Et
ensuite on est arrivé dans un projet euh
de pose des câbles à des vocations
économiques. Donc qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ? libéralisation des télécom qui
arrive 84 euh les États-Unis
libéralisent les télécom hein euh
découpent ET&T euh avec les Baby Bell
euh Margaret Tatcher privatiste British
Tellcom. Euh la Commission européenne
impose à tous les pays européens de
libéraliser leur télécom. Euh le monde
entier euh commence à à découvrir la la
téléphonie mobile, euh l'internet
commence à à débarquer, tout le monde
commence à poser des câbles et là les
câbles sont posés euh sur la base
d'intérêt économique, c'est-à-dire ce
sont des consortiums qui se mettent en
place. Euh ce ne sont plus des États qui
communiquent avec d'autres États euh
pour faire les raccordements, mais ce
sont en fait des opérateurs télécom avec
d'autres opérateurs télécom pour euh
poser des câbles en fonction de leurs
intérêts purement économiques. Et donc
les câbles qui sont posés ne répondent
qu'à des impératifs économiques.
Deuxième phase de ces impératifs
économiques,
les gars femmes arrivent et disent bah
nous on a des besoins et on a besoin de
déverser toutes nos productions, tous
nos contenus et donc les GFAMB
commencent à investir le champ des
câbles en disant "Ben nous aussi, on a
des intérêts économiques et quand
l'information arrive trop lentement
parce que on est obligé de faire trois
fois le tour de la terre pour arriver à
livrer nos paquets et notre vidéo, Bah,
ça nous pose un problème. On est obligé
d'augmenter nos capacités, on est obligé
de de déployer euh de déployer trop
d'énergie. Donc, on va poser nos propres
câbles. Donc, de nouveau intérêt
économique, euh les gars femmes
commencent à poser des câbles au côté à
côté dans des consortium, hein, toujours
parfois des opérateurs sans opérateurs.
Et on voit en fait que les câbles
s'installent en fait sur cette logique
sur la planète. Et puis là, on assiste
depuis quelques années à des stratégies
où en fait où les États ont décidé de
reprendre la main. C'est-à-dire qu'on
voit très nettement que les câbles sont
un enjeu majeur pour les États de la
même façon que le contrôle des MES par
les bases militaires
est un enjeu.
On voit que la pose des câbles, c'est un
gigantesque jeu de go. Alors, ce n'est
peut-être pas très évident.
dans en Europe, c'est peut-être pas très
évident
dans l'Atlantique, mais c'est une
bataille absolument extraordinaire
dans le Pacifique.
Ça se matérialise comment ?
Ben, c'est très simple. Une île a besoin
d'être raccordé pour l'ensemble de ces
activités économiques par pour
par à l'internet, par des câbles. Et la
question c'est est-ce que je prends un
câble américain ou est-ce que je prends
un câble chinois ?
Et en fonction de ça, vous avez une
bataille absolument terrible qui est une
bataille diplomatique, une bataille
économique et chacun en fait pousse ses
pions pour dire est-ce que euh ça sera
un câble américain ou un câble chinois
qui permettra en fait de faire que le
trafic partira de l'île vers entre
guillemets un circuit chinois ou un
circuit américain avant d'arriver dans
le circuit mondial de l'internet.
On parle de quelle île ?
à peu près toutes les îles du Pacifique
sont objets aujourd'hui l'objet euh de
bataille et ce d'autant plus que euh
l'augmentation des des flux et des
trafics fait qu'il y a une forme
d'obsolescence euh dans la taille des
câbles. Donc il y a quelques batailles
dans lesquelles mon entreprise a aussi
la la la chance de répondre à quelques
appels d'offre. Donc on voit bien on
voit bien les enjeux puisque
pe en parler ou pas ? Oui. Alors, on
peut parler de choses. Euh, la France
est un pays à ce titre-là extraordinaire
sur les câbles et et ça fait partie de
nos points d'excellence. Euh nous
possédons en France deux entreprises.
Euh alors, on pourrait se demander
comment on se fait on a on fait pour
avoir deux entreprises euh possédées par
l'État qui posent des câbles. Ça
pourrait poser la question euh de la
qualité de la gestion de nos actifs
stratégiques par l'État. Euh mais je
suis sûr comment j'ai pas bien compris
la fin de la phrase.
Euh mais je suis sûr que la question
reviendra. Euh donc nous avons deux
entreprises. Nous avons Orange Marine
qui est un des leaders mondiaux, un des
trois leaders mondiaux qui qui pose des
câbles sous-marins dans le monde entier.
Euh un câble sous-marin, c'est pas une
c'est pas une opération simple, hein.
Euh il y a ce qu'on appelle un répéteur,
hein. À peu près toutes les 80 km
suivant les technologies, on considère
que c'est à peu près 80 km. Un répéteur
des batteries qui permettent de
réamplifier le signal et de repartir et
cetera. Et puis on a une autre
entreprise qui est un peu plus qui est
un petit peu différente parce qu'elle
fait elle a deux activités. Elle
fabrique des câbles, elle fabrique aussi
ses fameux répéteurs. Euh elle est issue
d'Alcatel d'Alcatel, elle s'appelle
Alcaltel Subarine Network. Elle est
possédée à 80 % par l'État. Euh donc on
a d'un côté Orange Marine, de l'autre
côté Elcatel Marine Network. Et
évidemment, on peut s'interroger de
savoir pourquoi on ne fait pas une seule
entreprise parce que la ces deux
entreprises posent à peu près le tir des
câbles et les maintiennent parce que les
câbles, contrairement à ce qu'on peut
penser, en fait, c'est pas parce qu'on
les a posé une fois qui reste qui
restent comme ça dans l'eau, il faut
évidemment les maintenir al on les
maintient plusieurs fois d'une part
parce qu'il faut changer de temps en
temps les batteries qui sont qui servent
au répéteur hein pour réamplifier le
signal et pour permettre sur des
dizaines de de sur des milliers de
kilomètres de de transmettre le signal,
mais aussi parce qu'on a beaucoup
d'accidents euh on a beaucoup
d'accidents parce qu'il y a un câ ça se
rond. Euh
il a des Russes qui trébuchent dessus.
Oui.
Des Chinois qui trébuchent dessus.
Oui. Alors ça ça évidemment
des Américains qui trébuchent dessus.
Alors déjà euh déjà la première enfin
les les causes les causes les plus
amusantes, si on peut si on peut parler
un peu des causes de rupture de câbl euh
déjà dans la Méditerranée euh les câbles
sont euh régulièrement coupés euh par
les chalutiers raclants parce que au
fond de la mer, ils attrapent, c'est
strictement interdit bien sûr, mais ils
le font quand même. Ils attrapent non
seulement les poissons mais aussi les
câbles. Donc évidemment les câbles
passent à la casserole et ça fait que
régulièrement on a des incidents en
Méditerranée. Méditerranée euh n'est pas
très profonde et donc ce type d'incident
arrive. Vous
vous rappelez des révolutions arabes ?
Oui. Alors, il y a ça mais il y a il y a
eu aussi il y a eu
ou il y a ça
euh pardon ?
C'est quoi ? Il y a ça ? Euh non, mais
il y a eu quand je dis il y a eu ça,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a il y a le le le
il se trouve que euh en midi dernier, il
y a énormément de câbles qui relie
l'Afrique à à l'Europe et on a
régulièrement de des incidents qui
coupent euh les la connectivité entre
l'Europe et euh mais je je vais revenir
sur un sur un point parce que vous vous
je soulève un petit un petit détail
historique. Oui, un petit détail
historique mais plus qu'un détail
historique, c'està-dire une une question
de la géopolitique des câbles que j'ai
pas évoqué.
Mais on sait on a eu des ruptures de
câbles entre la France et et l'Égypte.
On a eu des ruptures de câbles entre la
France et l'Algérie principalement à
cause des des chalutiers. Après, on a
euh indépendamment des interventions et
des fameux sous-marins qui savent
découper des câbles et qui ont été
inventés pour ça euh et qui existent et
on sait euh on pourrait aussi parler des
nouvelles technologies sur les câbles
euh qui en fait font plus que
transmettre de l'information mais aussi
détecter ce qui se passe à côté d'eux.
Euh mais euh le le le
les causes de rupture, d'une part, il y
a beaucoup de causes naturelles. Alors,
les causes naturelles, vous allez me
dire c'est quoi ? Bah, les causes
naturelles, en fait, c'est un tsunami,
tremblement de terre, tsunami. On en a
pas parlé parce que Fukuyama euh
Fukushima pardon, Fukushima
a a monopolisé l'actualité. Mais il faut
savoir qu'à peu près 40 % de la
connectivité internet du Japon est
partie dans le décor à cause du tsunami.
C'estàdire tous les câbles entre les
États-Unis et le Japon ont quasiment été
coupés. Donc quand on a dit euh on
narrive plus à appeler le Japon parce
qu'il y a trop de personnes qui
appellent. Non non pas du tout. C'est
c'est pas parce qu'il y a trop de gens
qui appellent. C'est non seulement il y
a beaucoup de gens qui appellent, mais
en plus il y a 40 % des câbles qui sont
partis à la casserole et qu'il a fallu
qu'il a fallu re
remettre remettre en en connexion. Donc
il y a ça, il y a aussi en fait un un un
un phénomène amusant. Il y a les ancres
de bateau. Les ancres de bateau parce
que tout le monde pense évidemment à son
petit bateau personnel mais enfin il y a
des portes-avions. Euh ils ont des
grosses ils ont des grosses ils ont des
grosses englumes mais bah ils posent ils
posent
c'est le hasard
le hasard fait que oui c'est souvent le
hasard en plus c'est il y a absolument
aucune aucune autre logique mais en fait
il y a des gros bateaux qui qui qui
lâchent l'encre et pof ça tombe sur un
câble ça coupe le câble et donc ça
arrive donc on a beaucoup en fait de
maintenance de de rupture de câble et
donc et donc on a la chance d'avoir en
France deux de de deux grandes sociétés
qui qui qui ont à peu près qui ont à peu
près le le tiers du du marché. Pour
autant, hein, très clairement,
la volonté des grands États qui veulent
assurer la souveraineté et de construire
des flottes de câliers qui ne soient pas
dépendant qui ne soient pas dépendant de
de de la France ou de de du troisème
acteur qui est américain. Les Chinois
font des gros efforts là-dessus pour
construire des câbliers. Euh l'Inde
aussi réfléchit euh de façon très
active. Après, l'autre point qui est
celle de la géopolitique, c'est que les
États ont organisé euh les États ont
organisé un contrôle euh direct ou
indirect sur euh les politiques de
câblage euh des acteurs qui sont sous
leur autorité. Euh tout à l'heure, on
parlait du jeu de go des Américains et
des Chinois avec un coup de subvention
euh de d'intérêt économique dans le dans
dans dans le Pacifique. Euh mais on a eu
par exemple Donald Trump dans son
premier mandat premier mandat hein euh
qui a décidé que un câble qui devait
être fait en coopération entre les
Chinois et les Américains pour relier
Hong Kong ne devait pas être mis en
œuvre. Pourquoi ? parce que c'était
donné un avantage à la place euh
financière de Hong Kong. Et donc à ce
titre-là euh
c'était un consortium qui était dans
lequel je crois il y avait Google,
Facebook et une société chinoise et
finalement Donald Trump a dit non. Euh
et finalement, je crois que le câble
sous sous toute réserve est arrivé aux
Philippines ou en Indonésie à détourner
et finalement ne ce n'est jamais à Hong
Kong parce que l'idée c'était de dire si
Hong Kong est relié de façon trop
efficace euh ça permet euh d'améliorer
le le high frequency trading
et donc et donc à ce titre là à ce titre
là on ne relie pas Hong Kong. Alors, le
prétexte qui avait été pris à l'époque
était un prétexte de des fameuses des
fameuses révolutions en tous les cas où
ou meut qui se déroulaient à Hong Kong
et et donc et donc finalement Facebook
et et Google on avait avait convenu que
finalement le CAM n'arrierait pas
jusqu'à jusqu'à Hong Kong. Donc on voit
bien en fait comment l'État américain
prend en main en fait ses grands acteurs
et et discute avec ces grands acteurs en
permanence. De de l'autre côté, la Chine
a créé une société spécialisée pour
regrouper et demander à l'ensemble de
ces acteurs industriels de lui céder euh
le de le de de lui céder euh leurs
actifs euh utiliser leurs actifs qu'ils
possèdent dans les cas pour faire une
sorte de holding et pour maîtriser et
avoir une politique cohérente de de
câble. C'est ces deux stratégies
différentes. L'un se basant sur acteurs
privés, l'autre plus orienté
politiquement. Mais en tous les cas, la
volonté de de de faire ça est
importante. Évidemment, dans ces points
géopolitiques, on a la France qui a une
stratégie très très positive et très
offensive.
Orange, évidemment, il contribue très
très fortement.
C'est en fait c'est d'un d'être un point
de de de d'amérissage pour les câbles
qui viennent du côté atlantique de
l'autre côté
de l'autre côté d'arriver par la la
Médianée. Donc le Marseille Toulon sont
des des est un poste important. Euh le
le la côte la côte ouest est aussi
important pour que les câbles arrivent
plutôt qu'en Espagne, plutôt qu'en
Italie. Euh le trafic internet arrive
chez nous, ça permet de le disperser,
euh
ça permet de le surveiller,
ça permet euh euh ça c'est les les
mauvaises langues disent que ça permet
de le surveiller. Euh mais c'est
qui sont les mauvaises langues ? Ah
c'est ceux qui euh qui qui prétendent
qu'on qu'on surveille tout. Mais euh ce
qui est aussi intéressant, c'est que
économiquement ça rapporte de l'argent
parce que faire passer du trafic par son
réseau et est facturé. Donc il y a aussi
un intérêt économique indépendamment de
de la logique de de surveillance. Euh
ben je et quand quand la question euh du
jeu de go hein, que ce livre les les
États-Unis et et l'Asie euh sur euh sur
les îles dans ce pacifique euh n'est pas
forcément n'est pas forcément un
problème de surveillance, c'est
simplement euh la capacité à à dire que
finalement le câble marche plus
temporairement parce qu'il y a une
panne. Euh voilà et donc de mettre de en
situation de dépendance. Voilà, donc
c'est c'est plus ça peut être aussi ce
type de jeu là qui qui se joue et pas
forcément des logiques de de
surveillance parce que les données sont
cryptées. Alors vous allez me dire les
données sont cryptées
euh oui chiffré pour quelques années
encore le temps que finalement on a
stocké tout ce qui a été
tout ce qui est transmis et dans
quelques années les ordinateurs
quantiques commenceront à déchiffrer ce
qu'on a stocké quelques années avant.
Euh alors évidemment, il y aura une
partie de l'information qui sera
obsolète mais enfin sur des projets qui
sont à 20 ans à 30 ans, à 40 ans avoir
des des information sur des technologies
un peu de longue durée, que ça soit le
rafale, que ça soit les centrales
nucléaires, ça peut présenter un intérêt
d'être en capacité décrypter ce qui
s'est dit 5 ans avant et et donc et donc
évidemment évidemment ça interroge tout
le monde. Et peut-être le dernier point
sur les câbles, c'est les points
stratégiques. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
endroits où
les câbles sous-marins, ils doivent
quand même passer par la terre parce que
sinon, on arrive quand même pas à faire
le tour du monde facilement sans passer
par la Terre. Euh donc il y a deux trois
points nébralgiques qui sont importants
dans le monde et tout à l'heure vous
parlez de la laion du printemps arabe,
bah justement il y a un point
nébralgique he qui est le canal de Suè.
tout le long du canal de Suèse, vous
avez des milliers de câbles qui qui sont
là. Vous avez un autre point nvralgique
un peu plus bas qui est à Jibouti euh où
en fait il y a beaucoup de câbles qui
qui arrivent. Euh vous avez un un point
névralgique qui est le canal du Panama.
Le long du canal du Panama, c'est assez
simple de poser des câbles parce que si
on les pose au fond de la mer, c'est que
c'est quand même beaucoup plus simple de
les poser au fond de la mer que de
tracer de de de de les de creuser tout
le long. de la terre euh à l'intérieur
de de par exemple de leur rasie, hein.
Euh il vaut mieux faire un détour si on
veut aller de Brest à à Brestnop euh à
Vladivostock, pardon. Euh le il est
quand même plus facile de passer par la
mer que de passer par la terre. Donc
c'est c'est un peu moins compliqué.
Histoire de ligne droite.
Ouais. Voilà. et et le et donc
évidemment euh
et donc évidemment euh il y a il y a
quelques points libralgiques et c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs la question du
Panama est intéressante parce que quand
on regarde euh la
la politique de Trump
Ah oui, alors c'est plus que la
politique de Trump parce que euh le
canal du Panama est et qui fait qu'en
fait à peu près tous les câbles euh tous
les câbles qui desservent, on va dire,
l'Amérique latine de part et d'autre euh
donc à l'est et à l'ouest évidemment
passe par par
que c'est assez intéressant quand on le
lit euh c'est de regarder la fameuse et
le fameux projet sur lequel la COP 21 a
failli partir dans le décor, le fameux
projet du canal du Nicaragua. Et le
canal du Nicaragua euh est évidemment
accordé est une concession est une
concession qui est accordée aux Chinois.
Donc c'est un projet pharaonique qui
coûte des dizaines de milliards et qui
vise à créer une alternative au canal de
Panama euh
avec évidemment des questions de de
déforestation de de perturbation du du
système écologique local. donc qui fait
l'objet de beaucoup de critiques. Mais
il y a une clause un peu particulière
dans ce dans ce dans ce deal euh qui dit
que celui qui dispose de la concession
pour exploiter ce canal dispose aussi
d'une exclusivité pour le transit des
câbles
euh télécom. Donc on comprend bien que
faire passer ces câbles par le Panama ou
les faire passer par le Nicaragua, bah
globalement c'est pas tout à fait les
mêmes enjeux. Et on comprend bien que
les uns sont, on va dire dans un
écosystème, on va dire américain ou en
tous les cas dont les Américains
essayent de reprendre le contrôle alors
que d'un côté c'est dans un ça sera dans
un écosystème chinois. Mais la France,
de par son territoire maritime
absolument gigantesque a un rôle
absolument extraordinaire à jouer. Euh
tout à l'heure, on parlait de Cuba et
j'entends beaucoup de critiques. Je ne
suis pas je ne suis pas un un défendeur,
un ardent défendeur des des de la
politique cubaine et du régime politique
en place. Mais je constate juste une
chose euh c'est que on nous dit Cuba
boycotte l'internet. Non, c'est
l'internet qui boycotte Cuba. Les
Américains de par la politique de
l'embargo interdisent qu'un câble touche
à la fois Cuba et la Floride, 99 miles.
Donc vous imaginez que Cuba quand il
veut se raccorder à l'internet la
première fois, il le fait, pose un
câble. Alors évidemment, il y a des
vieux câbles pré prévolution castriste
qui permettent quand même encore
d'acheminer un peu le le téléphone.
Et il se trouve qu'il y a une très a un
très vieux traité un très vieux traité
qui en fait interdit au fait aux États
d'empêcher en fait les communications
pour aller d'un pays à l'autre. Donc
donc en fait un américain peut quand
même appeler un cuba. On peut pas lui
interdire un trait international que qui
n'a pas été qui n'a pas été rompu par ça
veut pas dire que il y a un accès direct
he je crois qu'il passe par le Canada
mais en tous les cas mais en tous les
cas et donc quand Cuba a voulu se
raccorder à l'internet en fait ils ont
été obligés de poser un câble entre Cuba
et le Venezuela
financé à l'époque
par Chavez c'est 1400 km.
99 1400 km pour arriver au Venezuela qui
est un pays dans lequel l'internet est
quand même un peu brinque ballant dans
lequel le la capacité et le débit était
pas forcément au rendez-vous
et donc finalement
les Cubains ont décidé d'être accordés à
la Martinique euh non sans difficulté
parce qu'il y a des eaux territoriales
dans lequel il faut poser le câble non
sans difficulté. Orange Marine l'a fait
avec Briot, le câble marche et les
cubins l'internet. Euh,
petite parenthèse, Orange Marine, c'est
un clin d'œil à Paul.
C'est un
clin d'œil à Paul et Luar ?
Non, pas du tout. Je crois que je crois
que Orange Marine, c'est simplement en
fait son nom c'est son nom parce que
parce que avant ça s'appelait français
comme Marine et que c'est devenu orange
marine. Donc voilà.
Revenons à à nos câbles. Cuba, la
Martinique, ceux qui déroulent du câble.
Est-ce qu'ils ont des cellules de
prospective
géopolitique, économique ? Est-ce qu'il
se creuse un peu le cerveau ou il
déroule du câble ?
Bah
la question la question cachée dans
cette question, c'est est-ce que les
services de renseignement vous
expliquent un petit peu par où il faut
passer où c'est dangereux ?
Non, je crois que je crois qu'il faut
avoir une vision qui est enfin toute
activité économique, toute activité
économique qui euh est critique pour un
pays euh et forcément rentre en relation
avec les États. J'ai d'ailleurs écrit un
enfin j'ai pas écrit parce que j'ai été
interrogé par un un journaliste de de
très grande qualité
au monde qui est qui est Jacques Foloro
euh qui me demandait en fait la relation
entre un état et un opérateur. Un état
est un état si un état est un état qui
veut assurer sa souveraineté sur ses
opérateurs télécom.
Euh il a suffisamment de leviers euh
pour lui demander euh de de faire de
faire ce qu'il veut.
Ça ça passe par le l'embauche et la
hiérarchie euh de la boîte.
Pas forcément.
Entre euh les systèmes de taxation,
entre la régulation,
entre les contraintes qui sont mises, la
sécurité nationale, les interceptions
légales et cetera. Globalement euh
voilà. pas les malins quoi. On obéit,
on obéit. Euh alors évidemment on obéit
dans le dans un cadre en général dans
notre démocratie qui est un cadre légal
et qui est encadré. Peux
vous poser une question à un
syndicaliste ? Oui, bien sûr. Si par
exemple on a un état euh qui devient un
peu trop totalitaire en France et que il
y a trop de des pays euh il y a il y a
il y a trop d'inspection ou de contrôle
de nos communications, est-ce que chez
Orange, il y a des patriotes qui vont
dire "Méfiez-vous les gars, ça commence
à sentir leur
je crois que la démocratie
c'est un c'est un équilibre extrêmement
fragile et qu'elle dépend et elle a
toujours dépendu
d'un nombre d'acteurs qui sont des
lanceurs d'alerte.
Euh je crois que la caractéristique de
notre maison et c'est pour ça que
personnellement j'y suis fortement
attaché euh
on embrasse
euh pardon
on embrasse votre maison. Non mais euh
mais je pense que c'est pas notre maison
qu'il faut embrasser. Ce sont les gens
qui l'ont construite. Euh non, mais
c'est vrai, je je vais je vais vous dire
des choses qui sont très très très
personnelles. Mais
on sent la petite larme.
Oui. Oui. Parce que parce que je suis là
parce que le téléphone existe. Euh
Belle, pardon.
À cause de Belle ?
Non non non.
Euh moi je suis né avant Belle. Euh le
le le
monsieur à quel âge ?
Mais vous pouvez vous pouvez sourire
mais mais mon prénom mes parents mes
parents ont hésité entre Sébastien et
Aurélien et et la génération B et
Sébastien, c'est c'est le le c'est 75 le
plus grand nombre de Sébastien qui qui
qui est né en France.
Euh et non non mais je je suis très
sérieux quand je dis ce sont les les les
femmes et les hommes qui qui ont
construit notre maison et dont on peut
globalement être fier. Euh même si moi
j'ai construit un opérateur alternatif,
donc j'ai vécu la concurrence et j'étais
un farouche défenseur de la nécessité
euh d'introduire euh sur certaines
couches euh des formes de concurrence
qui permettaient de l'innovation et je
crois toujours à ce que euh la
concurrence est nécessaire euh sur un
centre de services. En revanche,
j'ai acquis l'intime conviction
que les infrastructures uniques doivent
relever du régalien. Et nous sommes
partis dans une folie hystérique où le
le néolibéralisme
produit sa propre némésis sur les
infrastructures uniques. Vous n'imaginez
pas avoir deux rails de chemin de fer
côte à côte. Vous n'imaginez pas avoir
deux autoroutes l'une au-dessus de
l'autre. Vous n'imaginez pas avoir de
robinets euh dans chacune de vos pièces
d'eau parce que d'un côté vous avez la
générale et de l'autre côté vous avez la
lyonnaise. Et encore Coca-Cola vous
demanderez un troisème robinet pour
pouvoir vous servir du Coca-Cola. Donc
on voit bien par
pour l'électricité. Pareil pour
l'électricité, on a un réseau unique. On
a un réseau unique donc qui n'est pas
un peu un peu parasité, hein.
Un peu parasité, mais c'est plus la
production sur lequel on fait n'importe
quoi euh et sur lequel on on pourrait
revenir, mais c'est c'est pas forcément
mon domaine de de prédilection, même si
euh de par nos activités à la fois
syndicales et télécom,
on a beaucoup de de discussions euh sur
la question de d'électricité, des
réseaux électriques. Faut pas oublier
que le téléphone a eu son réseau
électrique indépendant et que le
téléphone était indépendant par lui-même
sur électricité, ce qui n'est plus par
là, ce qui n'est plus sur la sur la
fibre. Mais pourquoi je dis qu'en fait
il faut être fier de notre de notre pays
et de notre maison ? C'est un grand
paradoxe parce que c'est un des rares
chantiers dont la France peut être fière
sans le général de Gaulle.
Euh alors ça peut faire sourire mais un
général de Gaulle détestait le
téléphone. Général de Gaulle détestait
le téléphone parce qu'il a un
rendez-vous au moment du Front
populaire, un rendez-vous avec Léon
Bloom. Euh il veut lui parler de la
construction de division blindée parce
qu'il trouve que mettre des blindés dans
l'infanterie, c'est une idiocy. Le
téléphone les interromps quatre fois. Le
général de Gaulle n'a pas le temps de
présenter son projet. Euh Léon Bloom le
remercie et euh le général de Gaulle
part furieux et 3 ans après les
Allemands euh avec leur panzer division,
leur blitz Creeg démontrent que les
divisions de blindé étaient évidemment
la bonne option.
Donc le général de Gaulle euh le
téléphone trouve que c'est un élément de
perturbation des constructions
intellectuelles, des développements de
construction intellectuelle, des
échanges intellectuels et donc à a une
sorte d'aversion et c'est au final
Pompidou qui lance le plan téléphone que
Giscard Destin met en œuvre quelques
quelques années après. Et donc c'est en
78 où en fait on recrute le plus de
personnes pour déployer ce téléphone. Et
c'est pour ça que on a un téléphone qui
a pris beaucoup de retard entre
guillemets euh en partie à cause du
général de Gaul mais qui à contrario a
été très rapidement numérique. On
invente d'ailleurs le Minel à cette
occasion. Euh ce qui fait qu'on a pas
pris tant de retard que ça euh malgré ce
qu'on a pu lire dans la presse en disant
le Minitel empêche le développement de
l'internet en France. Non, euh en fait
tous les acteurs savaient ce que c'était
que les services en ligne et donc Card
ont été une rapidité extrême à à se
développer euh dans les services en
ligne et on avait des services
bancaires, on avait de la réservation,
on pouvait réserver ses billets de train
euh pas plus euh pas plus difficilement
qu'aujourd'hui, sauf queon avait une
interface qui était évidemment un peu
plus rudimentaire. Et ce téléphone, en
fait, il a été très important et il est
constitutif d'un ADN que notre pays a
perdu et que notre entreprise a perdu.
Euh le téléphone, ça sauve des vies. Il
y a peu de métiers qui sauvent des vies.
Euh bien sûr, le corps médical, euh bien
sûr euh les services de sécurité et les
pompiers qui sauvent des vies. Euh mais
il y a aussi téléphone. Les téléphones
le téléphone, il a été
consubstantiellement développé avec les
services d'urgence. le 15, le 17, le 18
sont des numéros de téléphone qui sont
intrinsèquement attachés au
développement du téléphone. Euh à l'âge
de 7 ans, euh c'est pour ça que j'ai une
émotion particulière quand je parle du
téléphone.
Euh à l'âge de 7 ans, euh j'étais un
gamin euh un peu agité et j'ai le
malheur au lieu de pousser une porte, la
poignée d'une porte derrière, j'avais
deux petits camarades de jeu chez mon
grand-père
dans le ma central. Je pousse le carreau
de la porte et donc je me coupe toutes
les je me coupe les veines, les tendons
du poignet droit. Mon grand-père faisait
partie des deux personnes qui dans le
village, c'est un village en vert donc
il y avait une le village était était
assez pentu. Enfin en tous les cas avec
un fort dénivelé, il y avait une
personne qui avait le téléphone en bas,
une personne qui avait téléphone en
haut, c'était mon grand-père et mon
grand-père a pu appeler les services
d'urgence. Et donc on a eu dans un délai
relativement rapide euh moi qui
m'apparaisse encore un temps aujourd'hui
extrêmement lent euh parce que j'avais
du sang partout sur moi euh et mon mon
grand-père a pu appeler les services et
donc j'ai une perfusion non pas une
transfusion parce qu'on en était pas là
à l'époque qui a permis à ce que jusqu'à
l'hôpital de Saint-Étienne je puisse
tenir sans sans arrêt cardiaque parce
que je perdais tellement de sang que que
que ça était terrible. Donc le téléphone
ça c'est une réalité et je pense que euh
chez chaque français, dans chaque
famille euh le téléphone a sauvé des
vies.
Vous pouvez me rappeler pourquoi le
téléphone a été créé ?
Alors ça c'est évidemment
c'est une histoire de femme encore ça.
Non
non non c'est c'est c'est alors le dépôt
de Grambel enfin le brevet alors il
faudrait que je le relise.
Le dépôt de Grambel je crois que
c'est une histoire d'amour.
Non non, c'est pire que ça. C'est euh
c'est en fait le le ça permet en fait le
téléphone dans le dépôt de de Grambel
euh la vocation du téléphone, c'est de
permettre aux riches bourgeois d'écouter
de d'écouter de chez eux l'opéra ou la
messe.
Donc donc c'est évidemment assez assez
drôle de voir que finalement en fait on
en avait une diffusion presque de
broadcast et qu'au final çaen est devenu
un un outil d'interaction
interpersonnelle. Mais cette
construction du du téléphone dans les
années 80, dans les années 80, il y a
pas la la création de du du je me trompe
peut-être, mais le téléphone, c'est pas
parce que sa femme était trop loin, elle
était malade, il a pas pu entendre.
Ah si. Alors après il y a toute une
histoire, il y a tout un imaginaire
autour du téléphone euh qui s'est
développé. On j'ai un temps j'ai voulu
raconter enfin un temps je me suis
demandé si je devais pas écrire un petit
livre sur les 20 histoires les plus
drôles du du téléphone. Euh
ça été triste hein.
Oui. Alors évidemment évidemment c'est
c'était parce que le derrière parce que
derrière c'est une époque où en fait on
commence à maîtriser
l'électromagnétisme, on commence à
maîtriser l'électricité, on commence à
maîtriser
le le la reproduction. Donc on a des
phonogrammes, on a toute une série de
choses. Donc on commence à comprendre
que finalement on s'est arrivé à
transmettre autre chose que que du morse
ou avec les sémaphores euh des systèmes
de des systèmes télégraphiques. Euh les
donc donc tout ça tout ça on le voit on
le voit progressivement émerger.
Évidemment, à certains moments, on se
dit que on se dit que finalement,
puisqu'on arrive à enregistrer des voix
sur sur des disques, pourquoi pas le
faire en temps réel. Et et donc
évidemment, il y a eu il y a il y a eu
quelques quelques imaginaires, mais je
rappelle quand même qu'au début du 20e
siècle, l'église condamnait le téléphone
parce que ça permettait aux amants de se
retrouver. Donc, on voit bien qu'il y a
tout comme ça,
vivre dans le péché.
Voilà. Et bien sûr, bah si forcément si
c'était des amants, c'était que c'était
quand même pas dans le cadre dans le
cadre légitime du mariage.
Donc donc on voit qu'en fait il y a
toute une histoire, il y a toute une
série d'anecdotes du du téléphone entre
évidemment qu'est-ce qui relève de
l'anecdote, qu'est-ce qui relève de
l'histoire, qu'est-ce qui relève de la
réalité, qu'est-ce qui relève de la
reconstitution. Euh tout tout ça était
évidemment amusant, mais je pense que le
téléphone en tous les cas depuis plus de
100 ans alimente notre notre imaginaire.
Et euh et donc le le le téléphone des
années 80 et le téléphone des années 90
euh c'est un téléphone qui sauve des
vies. Alors bien sûr le 15, le 17, le 18
dans sa première partie sur le téléphone
fixe, les arrêts cardiaques, les
maladies, les interventions, tout ça, ça
a permis évidemment au servic
d'intervenir beaucoup plus rapidement.
Mais on oublie aussi que la mortalité
sur la route entre les années 90 et les
années 2000 se réduit fortement parce
que les délais d'intervention en cas
d'accident se réduisent parce queon
appelle par téléphone mobile
immédiatement pour dire sur la RN 256
et ben
il y avait eu un accident certes mais il
fallait aller au village trouver une
cabine téléphonique appeler les services
d'urgence expliquer où est-ce qu'on
l'avait trouvé quelle voiture c'était à
quel angle et cetera, que c'est très
approximatif alors que là en fait On
décrochait son téléphone, on appelait
les les services d'urgence, on disait
"Il y a une voiture qui est dans le
décor." Parfois, il y avait des passages
à l'intérieur qui avaient un téléphone
qui pouvait appeler plus ou moins, même
s'ils étaient en plus ou moins bon état,
pouvait appeler. Euh et aujourd'hui, en
fait, toutes les voitures sont équipées
d'un système qui fait que s'il y a un
accident, c'est immédiatement transmis
au service d'urgence et et donc et donc
l'intervention se fait et on sait que le
facteur de survie le plus important,
c'est le délai d'intervention dans les
accidents graves. Donc la réduction du
nombre de morts sur à la fois sur sur
une série de sujets comme les
arcardiaques, comme les accidents et
cetera et sur la voiture, c'est en
partie grâce au à l'arrivée du
téléphone. Donc le téléphone sauve des
vies, c'est un ADN. Et et quand
j'entends quand je n'entends pas
justement
ceux qui dirigent à la fois notre pays,
à la fois secteur, à la fois notre nos
entreprises et qui ne disent qui ne
rappellent pas que le téléphone ça sauve
des vies, ça m'atriste parce que ça veut
dire que quelque part à la fois on perd
notre ADN, on perd notre culture, on
perd notre histoire, on perd le sens des
réalités, on perd on perd le sens des
priorités. Non, le téléphone c'est pas
une boîte de Nesquck qu'on achète sur un
dans sur un sur une étagère d'un
supermarché. Euh c'est un outil qui est
extrêmement important. Euh en Snook
quand il a quand il a lancé Orange en
Cathola bah après son étude euh qui a
été euh qui l'a faite parce que au début
euh son actionnaire qui l'a envoyé
pensait en fait fermer l'activité
en Angleterre euh a dit "Ce sera la
télécommande de la vie euh et
effectivement aujourd'hui le téléphone
c'est la télécommande de la vie euh mais
ça a été avant ça a sauvé des vies et et
ça reste l'outil essentiel pour sauver
des vies euh et Ça en sauve beaucoup
plus euh que quasiment tout autre moyen.
Vous parliez de lanceur d'alerte,
vous parliez de salarié, je vous parlais
de démocratie qui se rédit.
Le téléphone, c'est la télécommande de
la vie, mais ça peut être aussi la
télécommande pour éteindre tout le
monde, non ? Le renseignement, les
écoutes, les ingérences.
Est-ce que dans votre boîte, il y a des
gens qui essayent de rendre le système
plus robuste ?
susceptible de se faire attaquer, de
susceptible de se faire fuiter, de
susceptible de se faire écouter.
Je crois que le numérique a introduit
mais mais comme toute technologie une
fragilité. Euh
le le le
la maîtrise du feu la maîtrise du feu a
permis d'améliorer les conditions
euh et et l'espérance de vie de ceux qui
le maîtrisaient.
Euh quand une tribu perdait la maîtrise
du feu, euh c'était une catastrophe. Euh
pourquoi ? Parce que le feu ça permet
d'autres choses. Bien sûr, ça permet
la tribu France.
Euh oui, mais la tribu France pour ça
que je prends le feu et le téléphone
parce que je je considère que ce sont
ces ces ces deux parallèles qui sont
intéressants. Euh le feu et j'ai pour ça
que je vais vous donner quelques
exemples. Euh le feu, ça permet bien sûr
de se protéger contre les animaux. Euh
quand on est dans une grotte, ça permet
de se réchauffer quand il fait pas bon
et donc évidemment d'éloigner quelque
part la capacité d'être malade. Ça
permet aussi euh de faire cuire les
aliments, donc de diminuer le temps de
digestion, donc de permettre de
d'augmenter en fait l'espace de
réflexion euh parce que euh plus la
digestion est longue, moins en fait la
capacité de réflexion et de travail est
importante. Euh donc ça a été des
modifications profondes et donc on a une
forte déstabilisation le jour où on perd
la maîtrise du feu. Donc le jour où on
perd la maîtrise de ces
télécommunications, le jour où on perd
la maîtrise de son numérique, on est
effectivement dans une situation
difficile et on est dans une situation
de régression et on n pas forcément
d'alternative.
Ils en sont conscients nos politiques.
Non, je pense que aujourd'hui on on a
fait du numérique comme je le disais
tout à l'heure, des boîtes de Nesquck et
donc et donc on on a l'impression qu'on
achète un téléphone du d'une facilité
grande. Mais le numérique c'est pas que
le téléphone. Le numérique c'est aussi
nos moyens de paiement. Euh nos moyens
de paiement sont
alors pas tout en même temps. Les
politiques, ils ont pris conscience
qu'on était en train de se
Non, mais le les moyens de paiement sont
reliés par le téléphone euh parce que en
fait on a des des réseaux maintenant qui
sont fonctionnés en temps réel parce que
nous sommes passés de la carte de crédit
à la carte de débit, ce qui a été une
une chose importante et que désormais
euh on est capable entre guillemets si
on enfin on peut se faire éteindre
Donald Trump.
Alors, je dirais pas qu'on alors il se
trouve que la France a gardé
contrairement à beaucoup d'autres pays,
une autominie une autonomie sur son
système de paiement grâce au système du
GE carte bancaire et donc n'est pas dans
les mains de Visa ou de Mastercard. Et
donc la la triste expérience qui est qui
est arrivée au juge de la de la Cour
internationale à qui on a enlevé
la capacité d'utiliser Mastercard et et
Visa en plus de tous les de toutes les
plateformes qu'il avait. C'est trouvé
parce que il utilisait je crois au
Pays-Bas Visa et Mastercard mais en fait
il aurait eu une carte locale. Il se
trouve que les Pays-Bas ont aussi gardé
une souveraineté sur leur moyens de
paiement. Euh et donc et donc et donc il
aurait peut-être pas été coincé, mais en
tous les cas, on a vu comment une
désactivation euh faisait que que ça
pouvait pouvait poser un problème et et
finalement c'est une ingérence. La
France a gardé un un un modèle
d'autonomie au travers du Gocar bancaire
qu'il faut protéger euh pour ne pas pour
ne pas en dépendre. Mais mais derrière
aussi, il y a du téléphone. Donc si le
téléphone est interrompu, les cartes
bancaires ne fonctionnent plus. Euh donc
il y a un vrai il y a un vrai enjeu sur
euh sur le fait de garder sa
souveraineté euh sur sur le sur les
réseaux téléphoniques.
Les lanceurs d'alerte,
bah les lanceurs d'alerte dans le
numérique euh existent parce que la la
la puissance euh la puissance
aujourd'hui euh à la fois des puces, la
puissance des des réseaux, les
puissances de calcul, les capacités
d'analyse permettent de faire énormément
de choses. Euh je je moi je je le dis
très clairement et et la la et le le le
le le il y a des débats, il y a des
écrits dans dans qui font que que on
s'est interrogé très clairement en tant
qu'organisation syndicale sur la
capacité que pouvait avoir une
entreprise dans un cadre plus ou moins
légal parce que parfois c'est tout à
fait légal de de regarder les mails de
ses salariés, de faire une analyse
Et donc et donc qu'est-ce que dire ? Que
dire si une si une entreprise lance une
analyse sur l'ensemble des mails de de
ses collaborateurs ?
Même si en fait c'est un outil
professionnel, il ne reste pas moins que
ce sont des données qui peuvent être
traitées
qui peuvent être traité dans un contexte
qui peut être sensible parce que il y a
des sujets qui restent sensibles. Être
un syndicaliste, c'est
selon la RGPD une donnée sensible. Donc
évidemment ça peut nous interroger, ça
nous a interrogé, ça continue à nous
interroger. Euh et donc évidemment à ce
titre-là, euh quand on considère que euh
l'usage qui qui est fait de de ces
outils numériques extrêmement puissants
euh est excessif, euh oui, il faut euh
il faut donner l'alerte euh en disant on
on va trop loin, on est allé trop loin.
Après, ça pose un un problème qui qui
est récurrent hein, qui est
régulation, innovation, parce que sur
ces sujets-là, tout la loi ne prévoit
pas tout, on n'anticipe pas tout et donc
ça renvoie à quelques Moi, j'aime bien
citer cette phrase où on à la fois entre
guillemets ce cliché qu'on a qui est
dire l'Amérique innov, la Chine copie et
et l'Europe régule euh C'est je pense un
peu caricatural. Euh je pense
qu'effectivement il y a une forme de
liberté d'innovation aux États-Unis. Il
y a moins de de régulation même si au
final il y en a quand même une hein.
C'est quand même les premiers à avoir
inventé l'antitrust en tous les cas et
et avoir démantelé
SAR oil avec Rockfeller et et à l'avoir
transformé en cette compagnie. Donc
cette régulation concurrentielle a
existé aux États-Unis. Donc je pense
c'est un peu excessif comme comme
caricature et puis dire que la Chine
copie, je pense que c'est c'était
peut-être vrai à une époque mais ça les
plus vrai aujourd'hui. Je pense que la
la Chine sait innover euh sait faire des
choses tout à fait brillantes euh tout à
fait performantes dans des tas de
domaines. Euh peut-être pas tous euh et
peut-être heureusement encore pour nous.
Mais euh mais mais c'est mais en tous
les cas qui est important c'est que la
réflexion sur la régulation, elle
renvoie à quelque chose que Rablet euh
nous rappelait il y a 500 ans. Science
sans conscience n'est que ruine de
l'âme.
Et et donc et finalement la régulation
c'est la transcription de ce que disait
Rablé, c'est-à-dire peut-on utiliser la
science à toutes les fins sans la
réguler, sans penser à ses effets les
plus négatifs ? Et donc la question
c'est à quel moment doit-on réguler pour
éviter l'innovation ? Le débat par
exemple sur les données santé. Euh nous
avons nous sommes le pays qui avons le
plus de données santé structurées parce
que nous avons un système de santé qui
reste parmi euh les meilleurs du monde
malgré euh ses critiques sur son déficit
budgétaire, sur son organisation, sur un
tas de choses. Euh les femmes et les
hommes de nouveau qui le font
fonctionner euh le font remarquablement
bien fonctionner. Euh et nous avons
beaucoup de données de santé. Euh pour
autant, on les utilise très peu parce
que on a une régulation extrêmement
contraignante et la question c'est
est-ce que finalement nous ne perdons
pas des opportunités euh d'anticipation,
de prévention, d'analyse,
de recherche fondamentale parce que nous
n'exploitons pas ces données ? Donc
innovation, régulation sont sont des
sont des vrais sujets sur lesquels il
faut réfléchir et sur lequel il faut
trouver
un juste milieu dans une compétition
internationale
qui qui évidemment est complexe.
Régulation de l'IA.
Alors de nouveau régulation de l'IA, moi
je dis les I c'est des algorithmes et
c'est de la data. Donc euh
vous avez suivi l'histoire avec Claude
là récemment, du moins ça fait 6 mois.
Oui. Ah bah il y a eu
c'est quoi cette histoire là ?
Il y a eu beaucoup de choses hein sur
sur les sur les lien sur sur la rivière
agent.
Ouais. Alors il y a eu ça, il y a eu
Groc qui commençait à à repeindre toute
une série de de personnes de façon plus
ou moins dénudée. Bien en bikini.
Ouais pourquoi pasin ?
Il faut que je perde encore quelques
kilos. Euh mais euh monokini
mais euh oui mais ça ça empêche pas ça
empêche pas de voir les kilos. Euh non,
je crois que je crois que le le le Oui,
il y a il y a quelques interrogations
sur euh sur sur l'IA mais d'une façon
générale et pas simplement sur l'IA
générative.
Bien sûr, l'IA générative crée des
alternatives littéraires, crée des
alternatives
graphique, créer des alternatives
vidéos,
processus de création chez l'homme,
hein.
Oui. Alors,
non,
revenons à Claude.
Non, mais enfin sans sans aller sur le
le sujet de Claude, je pense que
si, on va aller sur sujet de Claude. Bah
enfin, moi je je le maîtrise pas
suffisamment pour pour
Claude Claude qui va bientôt se faire
débrancher. Claude se rebif. Claude
utilise les mails de son iné pour
simuler
on a simulé l'agent ayant accès à des
mails où il y a un scandale sexuel, une
tromperie ou quoi que ce soit
et Claude commence à à faire du chantage
pour éviter de se faire débrancher.
Ouais. Alors je pense
c'était une simulation.
Ouais. Je je je pense que je je pense
qu'il y a un peu de de romance. Je pense
qu'il y a un peu de romance dans tout
ça. Moi, je je suis très je suis très
factualisant. C'est-à-dire que le la
reproductivité des expériences est un
élément important pour éviter euh
96 % reproduit 96 % du temps, c'est euh
le même chantage.
Non, mais je je doute pas je je doute
pas du fait que si on on introduit les
les les mêmes données, on obtient les
mêmes réponses. Ça ça c'est la logique
de l'IA. Ce que je voulais juste dire,
c'est est-ce que le comportement du NIA
qui se fait débrancher est dans tous les
cas la même, c'est-à-dire de commencer à
utiliser des données personnels pour
dire non, j'ai pas envie de débrancher.
notion de de de protection qui a été
introduite peut-être par mes gardes
peut-être façon volontaire hein aussi
parce que l'algorithmie
l'algorithmie
permet d'introduire
sur des milliers de clés informatiques
des comportements qui sont pas forcément
très visibles, hein. Je je
enfin même dans un environnement qui ne
serait pas numérique,
on peut tout à fait introduire des
choses qu'on qu'on ne voit pas.
Autrefois, si on voulait surveiller
quelqu'un dans une conversation
téléphonique, on posait les pinces
crocodiles, hein. Et c'était très très
difficile à détecter. Donc on est un peu
dans la même mécanique, on a des
milliers de lignes de code et si à un
moment Et si à un moment il y a quelques
lignes de code qui prévoi qu'un
sousprogramme se mettre en action parce
que il y a il y a quelque chose qui qui
prévoit une entre guillemets agression
contre la machine, la machine commence à
à dérouler un autre processus mais pas
plus que ce que ce que les Américains
soupçonnent de sur les équipements
chinois qui sont les bacs d'or, pas plus
que et cetera. Porte dérobé.
Oui, portes dérobé. Donc des portes
dérobées qui feraient que si un code
particulier était envoyé, le
comportement de la machine ou de
l'équipement se trouverait modifié soit
en étant soit en tombant immédiatement
en panne, soit en
comme les Porsche en Russie, quoi.
Voilà. Ou ou même ou même ou même
simplement un détournement des données
ou simple et cetera. Donc donc ces
questions se posent quand on fait quand
on regarde de façon un peu plus
attentive, on s'aperçoit que oui, le
numérique fait que on peut tout à fait
glisser on peut glisser quelques
quelques quelques lignes de code qui euh
qui envoient des données non
volontaires. Ça, il y a eu pas mal
d'incidents sur sur ce sujet-là. Et donc
euh et donc si quelques lignes de code
ont été euh introduites pour euh
pour dérouler entre guillemets un
scénario, bah les lignes de code ont été
introduites puis le scénario s'est
déroulé et puis on s'aperçoit que oui,
il y a un problème. Donc euh moi je je
considère pas que je considère pas que
cet incident est la conscientisation de
la machine pour que elle protège sa
propre existence. Croyez pas à Skynet,
c'est des sujets différents. C'est que
je pense que je pense que je pense que
je pense qu'on peut avoir des mécanismes
programmés de protection euh de de la
machine pour empêcher sa désactivation.
Donc euh ça ça c'est des mécanismes qui
sont qui sont écrits. Euh le risque
majeur mais il était il a été décrit
dans docteur Folamour hein. Euh donc
voilà enfin ça rubrique nous a déjà tout
expliqué hein. Il y a un incident
diplomatique entre l'Union Soviétique et
et les États-Unis au moment de la guerre
froide. Il y a un avion qui perd dans
une dans un accident technique ou une je
sais plus une confrontation une
confrontation militaire perd son
équipement de communication et donc il
va lâcher la bombe nucléaire parce que
on narrive plus à le on narrive plus à
le rappeler. Ben voilà, c'est un
incident qui arrive et donc qui
efflanche la catastrophe. Pas besoin de
numérique pour déclencher une
catastrophe hein. Donc donc tout tout ça
existait. Alors évidemment, c'était
c'était c'était les fantasmes de la
guerre froide et du déclenchement
possible accidentel de de la guerre
froide. Oui, on peut avoir des
mécanismes qui qui nous amènent
comme comme tout système à à des des
phénomène imprévu, à des
dysfonctionnements qu'il faudra être en
capacité d'arrêter et sur lequel il y
aura une réflexion d'une forme de
régulation qui font qu'on puisse le cas
échéant si ça va trop loin débrancher la
machine. Oui.
Revenons à nos politiques.
Est-ce qu'ils sont un petit peu
conscients que n nos services de télécom
? Quelle réaction ils ont par rapport à
Space X ? Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont ?
Ah ouais, de deux sujets différents.
Oui, mais connex. Oui, connex mais mais
différents. Euh
peut-on parler de politique en France en
ce moment ?
Est-ce qu'il reste des politiques en
France en ce moment ?
Il en reste
lesquels ? Euh
il en reste, je je me permettrai pas de
de faire de de de
de prosélitisme, mais il en reste.
OK. Alors, si vous voulez pas faire de
prosélitisme, est-ce que vous pouvez
nous désigner ceux moins à votre sens,
du moins ceux qui n'ont pas un cuit
négatif ? Non, je crois que je crois
qu'il existe euh il existe euh des gens
compétents euh dans tous les parti
politique. Euh la question c'est
sont-ils aux manettes ou ne sont-ils pas
aux manètes ? Ça c'est une vraie
question. Mais en tous les cas, la
question de la conscience de de
l'importance des télécom, moi je ne me
fixe pas sur le je ne me fixe pas sur le
sur les politiques français, mais j'ai
suffisamment voyagé dans le monde et
j'ai suffisamment travaillé euh
notamment pour Orange euh au travers
d'opérateur Télécom parce que j'ai même
lancé un opérateur télécom virtuel en
Arabie Saoudite euh qui qui a qui n'a
pas connu qui a connu un très grand
succès mais très très furtif parce que
il y a eu des attentats en Arabie
Saoudite qui ont qui ont obligé les
politiques à prendre des décisions
radicales pour protéger leur pays et
donc à à contrôler extrêmement
sévèrement ceux qui prenaient un
téléphone parce que les attentats
avaient été déclenchés par téléphone
mobile. Euh donc ça a réduit la capacité
à agir sur sur des opérateurs virtuels.
Mais tous les pays aujourd'hui
n'acceptent pas l'ingérance étrangère
sur leur télécom. Je vais vous donner
juste deux exemples très
Est-ce qu' Non mais moi ils acceptent
pas mais ils peuvent peut-être pas faire
autrement. Non.
Ah bah si c'est très simple. Je vais
vous donner deux exemples. Vous allez
comprendre.
Euh un jour monsieur Boloré dans une
opération financière vend des actifs
télécomzand
et vend à Téphonica. Euh à Téphonica, il
lui rachète des actifs
chez Télécom Italia. On l' échange de sa
participation d'un téléphonica. Il se
retrouve avec à peu près le quart du
capital de Télécom Italien.
Vous avez le droit de parler de ça ?
C'est dans la presse.
Ah oui oui oui, c'est totalement public.
C'est c'est l'aventure de de c'est
l'aventure de Boloré et de Téléphonica
euh de de Boloré. Enfin tout ça tout ça
est l'information totalement publique et
et et et très connu. Le gouvernement
italien le prend très mal.
Euh considérant que c'est une ingérence
que c'est une ingérence
française peut-être. Alors
Vincent Boloré a été très actif en
Italie pendant une époque et était assez
respecté. Euh et puis euh les choses ont
fait que voilà le le le patronat italien
sans doute un un contexte en tout cas
les 25 % chez TCOM Italia de Bolloré
sont sont très très mal passés pour le
gouvernement italien et donc le
gouvernement italien a décidé de
reprendre le contrôle de Télécom Italia.
Comment il a pris le contrôle ? Kousumou
très simplement, il a appelé sa il a
fait quelques opérations financières. Il
a appelé la poste et la caisse de dépôt
et puis il leur a dit "Vous débrouillez,
vous rachetez le capital et puis vous
mettez en minorité Vincent Bolloré
et et puis globalement Vincent Boloré
est sorti avec une moin-value sur la
presse."
Donc souveraineté sur Télécom Italia
absolu. L'État italien a dit Télécom
Italia, c'est l'Italie. Donc monsieur
Boloret, merci beaucoup mais ça sera
sans vous.
Euh l'Arabie Saoudite au travers de de
son opérateur STC hein Saudi
Télécompagnie
décide de racheter 10 % de Télécom
Italia
de pardon TPON rachète des 10 % de
Téléphonica donc intrusion dans
l'opérateur historique qui représente 50
% de la valeur économique des Télécom en
Italie.
euh pas forcément le plus grand nombre
d'abonnés puisque le plus grand nombre
d'abonnés pour l'instant on est à un
touche touche avec Orange mais
en tout les cas en terme de valeur
économique qui représente 50 % du
marché, ils ont les entreprises, ils ont
des infrastructures, ils ont un nombre
de choses et et donc réaction immédiate
du gouvernement espagnol déjà pour
monter à plus de 10 %agol
du gouvernement espagnol. Oui, puisque
c'est téléphonica. Euh vous avez pas le
droit de monter à à plus de 10 % sans
respecter un sombre de règles. Donc euh
les euh STC est à 9,90.
Euh et immédiatement le gouvernement
espagnol rachète 10 % de téléphonica.
Donc euh donc les États euh les États
réagissent et c'est les États souverains
qui réagissent. Euh
la France est encore souveraine.
La France est encore souveraine. Euh
aujourd'hui euh je pense que euh l'État
français n'entend pas euh euh n'entend
pas abandonner sa souveraineté dans la
télécom. Euh il y a un grand débat qui
agite sans doute l'État et et qui est
important qui est euh que faisons-nous
des conseillations de satellitaire ? Et
ça rejoint cette fois-ci votre deuxième
question. Euh les États souverains ne se
dessaisiront pas de leurs opérateurs
télécom. Alors, évidemment, ça pose
quelques questions sur des États qui
deviennent, on va dire, plus souverains
qu'il n'était hier et qui se sont euh
malheureusement délesté de leur
opérateur. Euh donc ça ça pourrait
amener à quelques à quelques
modifications de de leur politique.
Euh la question cette éit devient une
question effectivement très importante.
C'est-à-dire que le projet euh ou les
projets américain et pas qu'américain
euh de Starling et de de d'Amazon Léo
euh pose la question de la souveraineté
euh parce que aujourd'hui on a un
système qui est en dehors du droit
commun. Alors on habille ça avec des
soi-disant licences. Bon enfin si je
prends le système Starlink,
moi la question que je pose c'est quand
vous mettez alors déjà Starlink je crois
est en France immatriculé comme un
fournisseur de matériel électrique
euh parce que en fait ils fournissent
des antennes donc ils sont ématriculés
comme ça. Ils ont obtenu une licence
auprès d'une autorité de régulation.
Moi, à titre personnel, je pense que les
autorités de régulation ne servent pas à
grand-chose. Je pense que c'est une un
abandon de de la souveraineté euh et un
renoncement régalien. Donc, je suis
assez personnellement hostile aux
autorités prétendument indépendantes qui
n'en indépendant que le nom. puisque de
toute façon euh les gens qui les ont
désignés euh les ont désignés et puis
quand ils les s'ils ont pas exercé
correctement leur mandat n'obtiendront
pas un autre poste dans une autre
autorité ou un autre ailleurs. Donc
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
l'indépendance euh de ces autorités ? et
surtout quand on invente sur la
cotutelle du ministère des télécom. Donc
on se demande euh quel brique à brac on
a inventé, mais enfin derrière on a
l'Europe qui a voulu des autorités
prétendument indépendantes. Et quand on
voit qu'en fait on attribue des licences
gratuites pour pouvoir émettre sur tout
le territoire,
qu'on accepte que les interceptions
légales se fassent à Francfort,
on se dit bah écoutez si on veut avoir
des activités un peu hors du champ
traditionnel, euh bah vaut mieux avoir
du Starlink parce que le temps qu'on
fasse une réquisition judiciaire
le temps qu'on fasse une réquisition
judiciaire en Allemagne pour récupérer
vu le fonctionnement un peu complexe des
des deux des deux systèmes judiciaires.
C'est joliment dit,
on peut avoir un peu de temps devant soi
pour finalement faire son opération puis
disparaître. Donc évidemment, ça pose la
question du régaillen, c'est-à-dire
peut-on accepter sur le territoire
national euh et d'ailleurs l'État est
intervenu hein sur l'idée que tel s
vente c'était les ports.
En tant qu'actif, l'État a dit non, je
n'accepte pas que cet actif que je
considère comme stratégique soit vendu
en tant qu'actif indépendant
à un fond de à un fond de pension
externe parce que je considère que c'est
un actif et je crois que c'est tout le
débat est posé, c'est-à-dire que on a eu
une première vague des télécom qui a été
le téléphone fixe. On a une deuxième
vague qui a été la téléphonie mobile sur
lequelle on voit bien que la capacité
des opérateurs
à rentrer sur les marchés est quand même
très contrôlé par les États
qui ce qui empêche pas d'avoir un modèle
économique qui fonctionne hein mais
auquel ils doivent rendre beaucoup de
compte. Euh on a une 3e vague qui est
maintenant la vague satellitaire qui
pose des tas de questions parce que les
les masses financières à mettre en œuvre
sont absolument gigantesque et ne
relèvent plus en fait d'une simple
territorialité géographique euh donc
très partielle euh mais ce chiffre en en
en en peut-être en dizaines de milliards
d'investissements
qu'il faut conduire et peut-on accepter
de laisser le ciel à Elon Musk ou à Jeff
Bezos même si Jeff Bos C'est plus aux
affaires, on va dire que c'est à Amazon.
Non, je crois pas. Je crois qu'on a une
vraie on a un vrai débat. Nous ne devons
pas accepter que des communications
puissent transiter
hors de hors du contrôle de de l'État.
Il y va de nos sécurité nationale, il y
va de nos souverainetés. Euh et je pense
que c'est un sujet que qu'on a mis sur
la table. Alors nous évidemment en tant
qu'organisation syndicale, vous allez me
dire qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Bah
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ? La première
fois, on l'a laissé passer sur Starlink,
c'est une erreur. La deuxième fois sur
Amazon Léo, on a décidé de saisir le
conseil d'étape parce que les conditions
d'attribution des licences sont
totalement léonines à la fois parce que
d'un point de vue de taxation, d'un
point de vue concurrentiel,
pas de fréquence, d'obligation légal,
pas de pas d'obligation légales et et
donc des des véritables risques pour la
souveraineté de notre pays.
Donc oui, on se on se base, ce qui ce
qui m'interpelle le plus, c'est d'être
un des rares acteurs ou que que nous
soyons un des rares acteurs à prendre
conscience. Alors la la réponse des
opérateurs et dit "Oui, oui, ça sera
régulé dans le temps, on verra, il y a
pas besoin de se précipiter et cetera."
Euh moi je j'aurais envie de dire je
pense que dans notre pays euh il y a des
acteurs qui réfléchissent très fortement
à aux impacts que le satellite peut
avoir.
Je pense que qui ont la puissance
financière ou en tous les cas qui ont un
écosystème de puissance financière qui
leur permet de réfléchir.
Je pense que un acteur comme comme
Xavier Niel est tout à fait capable de
de nous de nous
projeter dans la compétition
internationale qui qui est absolument
indispensable pour pour trouver notre
indépendance.
Il est tard parce que Xavier Niel
on a pas
Oui mais je pourquoi je dis Xel ? Je dis
Xiniel parce que l'État aujourd'hui
se montre totalement
insuffisant. C'est-à-dire que Hôtel Sat,
il met un petit peu d'argent dessus et
on lui a rappelé mais euh quand
j'entends dire le rapatriement de 40 440
satellites qui étaient fabriqués en en
en Floride et tout le monde se félicite
que demain ces 440 satellites soient
rapatriés en France à l'usine d'Airbus
dans les usines d'Airbus à Toulouse. Je
rappelle juste que la FCC FCC auquel
l'organisation
autorité de régulation donc la Fédéral
Communication Commission
auquel la CFOGC d'ailleurs a écrit
d'ailleurs a écrit sur les mêmes
arguments que Elizabeth Warrenz qui nous
a fait sourire
en disant laissez 15000 satellites dans
le ciel Elon Musk sur l'Orbite basse où
son satellite c'est de la pure folie
c'est lui accorder un monopole de fête
de contrôle des télécommunications
mondiales
et que on voit que que l'État doit
mettre plusieurs milliards sur la table
qu'il ne l'aim pas, que le projet Iris,
ce projet européen est dénoncé par les
Allemands et va partir dans le décor
parce que
comme les Allemands
après ayant fait mes études en
Allemagne, je pense que je pense que les
Allemands ne se sont jamais entendus
avec les Français. On a eu le royaume
des francs et nous avons l'empire nous
avons eu le Saint-Empire germanique et
et nous avons euh deux cultures, deux
histoires qui font que nous nous
entendrons pas et et personnellement je
pense que l'Union latine de Napoléon 3
avec l'Italie, l'Espagne, le Portugal et
serait beaucoup plus cohérente et et
constructive. Je pense que les cultures
sont en tous les cas la culture
européenne bien sûr il y a il y a les
fondamentaux de culture, mais il y a en
tous les cas une rivalité économique,
une rivalité de puissance, une rivalité
terrestre. Alors, autre autre fois, on
parlait des Bourbons et des Habsburgs,
mais finalement on a remplacé ça entre
une rivalité une rivalité un peu
différente. Alors, ça été une rivalité
entre les Allemands et les anglais mais
aujourd'hui en fait, on voit qu'on a
énormément de mal à construire des
projets avec les Allemands. Ne parlons
pas du scaf euh qui qui pourrait aussi
tourner au vinaigre. Il risque de
Parlons pas du nucléaire,
ne parlons pas du nucléaire. Ils ont ils
ont non plus. Donc finalement, il il
nous pompe notre énergie et notre
électricité à des prix indécents.
Euh mais au-delà de ça, au-delà de ça,
le le le
projet Iris 2 semble très en péril parce
que si les Allemands souhaitent un
système, ce qu'on peut comprendre, pays
souverain, armée voulant un système
indépendant,
permettant d'agir de façon autonome et
on a vu l'influence de Starling et on
voit encore l'influence de Starling dans
la guerre entre l'Ukraine et et la
Russie, hein, entre le moment où Elon
Musk a euh coupé pendant quelques heures
les communications à Starling et l'armée
ukrainienne était aveugle et de l'autre
côté ce qui se passe avec les Russes qui
ont réussi à pirater Starling, ce qui
évidemment interpelle ou en tout cas
l'utiliser pour piloter un centre de
d'opération d'opération contre
l'Ukraine.
Là, ils ont ils se sont fait sauter là.
Oui oui mais enfin ils y sont quand même
arrivés à un moment sans que personne
n'ait rien vu. Donc évidemment ça
interpelle ça interpelle sur la
fragilité de ces systèmes. Et si les
Allemands veulent avoir leur système
d'acte, la question c'est combien de
milliards devons-nous mettre sur la
table pour rester un pays souverain ?
Sachant que derrière, contrairement aux
Allemands, nous n'avons pas un
territoire forcément enfin uniquement
métropolitain.
Nous avons un territoire des territoires
d'outre mer avec des millions de
personnes qui sont sur ces territoires.
Et donc et et donc on a une
interrogation à avoir sur ce que nous
voulons faire de de notre puissance
satellitaire
et de notre industrie.
Arian a été pendant quelques quelques
dizaines d'années au singulier
le leader mondial de de de l'envoi de
fusée. Aujourd'hui, qu'est-ce qu'on est
? On est à 150 200 fusées envoyées par
Elon Muskre Arian va arriver en en faire
va arriver à faire h tirs dans l'année.
Donc on voit bien on voit bien que Prime
ça vous parle ? Non, pas pas en l'état,
mais euh mais Jeff Bezos fait la même
chose euh avec Blue Origin sur euh pour
envoyer aussi des des fusées. Euh les
Chinois envoient des fusées à
répétition, donc on on a des vrais
enjeux. Alors évidemment la question
c'est Europe Europe débat éternel euh
qui qui se pose. Est-ce que la France a
la taille nécessaire ? Est-ce que la
France n'a pas la taille nécessaire ?
Est-ce qu'un pays peut acquérir des
expertises sur des domaines très
spécifiques pour être un leader
incontournable ? Oui,
il y a eu des des pays où à certaines
époques
les les expertises étaient étit
concentré
et le colbertisme par exemple a a
consisté à sortir entre guillemets
de de ces pays ou à faire sortir parfois
par des méthodes peu recommandables
d'espionnage euh faire sortir des
technologies qui qui étaient à Venise
pour les importer en France. Quoi ?
l'optique. Non, ça c'était chez les
Allemands, ça
voilà. Mais des choses mais il y a eu à
toute époque des pays qui ont su
développer des écosystèmes extrêmement
brillant, être des leaders. La question
c'est est-ce que la France veut avoir un
écosystème spatial ? On a un écosystème
militaire extrêmement brillant. On est
le deuxième exportateur mondial. Al vous
allez me dire le militaire c'est
épouvantable.
Le militaire tant que ça sert qu'à se
défendre, c'est une bonne chose. Là où
le militaire pose un problème, c'est
quand ça sert à attaquer. Euh la bombe
nucléaire française est une chose
merveilleuse parce qu'elle nous a
protégé de toute agression
euh physique de toute nature. Pendant
quelques décennies, le parapluie
nucléaire français était quelque chose
d'exceptionnel. Donc çaen est jamais
servi. Donc voilà. Après euh le le le
l'économie militaire permet d'irriguer
des tas d'économies civiles. Euh et la
question par exemple de la
réindustrialisation de la France passe
par passe peut-être par effectivement un
maintien de notre sécurité euh qui passe
par un renforcement de nos capacités
militaires. Quel budget, quelle
ambition, quelle
voilà et donc évidemment ça renvoie à
des tas de questions qui renvoient au
régalien, le régalien, le régalien, le
régalien. Euh un vrai sujet euh
pour le Frexit,
je crois que je crois qu'on a à repenser
très clairement euh le rapport on a à
repenser très clairement euh le rapport
de ce qu'est l'Europe euh par rapport au
monde et on a à repenser le rapport de
la France par rapport à l'Europe.
le fait que sur trois sujets qui
concernent fondamentalement notre pays à
savoir
les accords internationaux sur les
questions agricoles
et en tous les cas le mercur sur lequel
la France s'est fait mettre en minorité
de façon assez sévère doit évidemment
nous interroger
c'est la France ou Macron ?
C'est la France.
Macron c'est la France. espagnols, les
agriculteurs espagnols sont dans la rue
en ce moment. Oui.
Euh donc je je considère que si les
agriculteurs espagnols sont dans la rue
aussi, c'est que l'Espagne a aussi un
petit une petite interrogation à avoir.
Donc je pense pas qu'on on puisse
focaliser ça sur sur le le le président.
Alors le président peut de par sa
politique et de par son entre gens avoir
une responsabilité. En tous les cas, les
agriculteurs espagnols sont aussi dans
la dans la rue sur la question du merco.
Euh premier premier échec quand même
très clair pour notre pays au détriment
de nos intérêts et et nous ne sommes
plus une puissance euh agroalimentaire
exportatrice, ce qui est quand même un
vrai sujet puisque c'était dans la
balance commerciale et c'est la première
fois que ça se produit cette année. Nous
sommes déficitaires, nous étions
excellentires. Or, c'est un élément les
rentrées les rentrées financières sont
un élément de notre souveraineté.
C'est-à-dire que nous devons avoir une
balance commerciale excédentaire euh si
nous voulons pouvoir lancer des projets
ambitieux dans d'autres secteurs. Le
deuxième sujet, c'est euh nous avons
perdu la bataille euh nous avons perdu
une deuxième bataille qui est celle de
la les normes sur le cloud et sur la la
sécurisation numérique.
Donc cette deuxième bataille, elle est
quand même assez inquiétante parce que
elle ouvre la porte aux technologies
américaine
contre lequel globalement
tout le monde
se est en train de de se lever en disant
"Attendez, si tout le cloud est
américain, on va quand même avoir un
petit souci." Et faire du cloud
souverain sans sans technologie
américaine, s'avère quasiment
impossible. Donc euh donc il faut quand
même qu'on arrive à remettre des des
contraintes qui euh qui qui fassent que
on arrive quand même un peu à sécuriser.
Donc le fait que nous ayons perdu cette
bataille de de de de normalisation,
hein. Et la normalisation est un est un
champ de bataille politique, hein. euh
est qui est en et la troisème bataille
que nous ont perdu, c'est mais tout ça
dans un délai extrêmement court hein, le
le mois qui vient de s'écouler, les
semaines qui viennent de s'écouler,
c'est la bataille qui est que l'argent
que nous envoyons en Ukraine,
indépendamment de savoir si nous devons
envoyer de l'argent en Ukraine ou pas
qui qui divise très clairement les
Français. Euh le euh le le fait que nous
n'arrivions pas à faire que les
Ukrainiens avec l'argent qu'on leur
donne achètent des équipement européens
est profondément hallucinant. Euh enfin
je je enfin ben notre équipement, nos
équipements militaires sont largement de
nature à permettre à l'Ukraine de
défendre son intégrité territoriale.
Enfin le rafale est considéré comme un
avion d'une très grande qualité. Euh nos
chars, nos sous-marins, nos nos bateaux
sont achetés par un un se pays
étrangers. Nos sous-marins, on peut rire
d'ailleurs de l'aventure des Australiens
qui ont préféré choisir des sous-marins
qui n'arriveront jamais. Mais euh mais
globalement,
c'est quoi ? C'était Ocus ou Cucus ?
Oui, enfin une affaire abracadabrante où
les Américains on ont fait rompre un
contrat qui était d'ailleurs pas les
sous-marins nucléaires, mais enfin tous
les cas, les Américains ne livreront
jamais dans les temps prévus les
Australiens qui vont se retrouver
pendant une certaine période sans
sous-marin de qualité suffisante pour
faire de la location. Oui. Enfin bon, on
va voir
du leasing.
Oui, on va revenons à l'Ukraine.
L'armement français Cocorico.
Oui, mais l'armement français,
l'armement français, c'est aussi une
histoire. Euh, c'est une histoire, c'est
une histoire aussi une histoire de
famille.
Pourquoi ils achètent pas européens les
Ukrainiens ? Parce que on peut pas
fournir. On n pas la chaîne logistique,
on n pas les chaînes de production.
Parce que c'est
moi je je ne suis pas le gouvernement
ukrainien. Le la simple chose que je dis
c'est que l'Europe aurait pu décider de
voter que quand nous versons des
dizaines de milliards à l'Ukraine, la
condition sinéquanon, c'est d'acheter
européen. Je ne vois pas en quoi ça
empêchait l'Ukraine de disposer
d'équipements de qualité. Et quand on
ils auraient moins reçu de renseignement
américain s'ils achetaient moins
américain.
Oui, mais la question c'est nous qui
donnons l'argent donc c'est nous qui
fixons les règles.
C'est simple, c'est c'est c'est
enfin ça ça me paraît quand même assez
simple si on a une population qu'on
qu'on
C'est assez simple. Pourquoi c'est pas
fait ? Bah parce que justement des des
intérêts des intérêts euh euh
contraires, des ingérences étrangères
viennent interférer pour que euh
certains pays et c'est peut-être le
principe de la démocratie européenne qui
est en cause, hein. Euh euh moi j'ai
beaucoup de mal à accepter que mon vote
soit 10 soit fois moins important qu'un
vote maltis au Parlement européen. Euh
donc évidemment ça me pose un petit
souci. Donc euh ces ingérences ces
ingérences-là ont fait que on n'a pas
réussi à faire adopter ces ces
dispositions-là. C'est des dispositions
contraires aux intérêts de l'Europe,
c'est des dispositions contraires aux
intérêts de la France, c'est des
dispositions contraires aux intérêts des
citoyens français.
On a encore plein de sujets à traiter
mais ça fait déjà 2h21 que nous sommes
en direct. Je vais prendre quelques
questions internet. Je demande comme on
ne veut plus aller sur Discord parce que
on est obligé de donner sa carte
d'identité, son autonification faciale
et que on ne sait pas comment ces
données vont être sécurisées proprement,
pas proprement et si ces données vont
être euh accessibles par des tiers de
confiance ou pas de confiance ou
quelques gentils petits pirates ou des
états. Donc nous sommes sur Twitter, on
a ouvert un poste avec marqué "Envoyez
vos questions" ou les questions ici.
Question internet. Quel genre de données
une entreprise comme Orange peut
récolter ?
Beaucoup de choses
sans déconner.
Mais c'est pas Orange qui c'est pas la
question, elle se elle s'adresse pas
Orange. La question, elle s'adresse à
qu'est-ce qu'un opérateur télécom
récolte comme donnée sur vous ? Bah
c'est très simple.
Euh bon, on va prendre les c'est c'est
de la technologie, mais ça je dire ça je
je pas je vais pas dire qu'au chat GPT
pourrait répondre à ma place mais euh
mais presque euh parce que c'est dans le
domaine public. Euh vous avez deux types
de données. Vous avez les types de
données, vous avez les types de données,
on va dire, qui qui passent par votre
téléphonie fixe et puis vous avez été
les données qui passent par votre
téléphonie mobile. Euh la première
donnée déjà qu'on est capable de de de
ça de connaître, c'est là où vous êtes.
Que ça soit sur le fix ou sur le mobile,
on sait où vous êtes.
Déjà, c'est une donnée qu'on avait pas
autrefois qu'on avait pas avant
l'arrivée. Alors, vous allez me dire
comment on le sait ? On le sait très
simplement parce que chaque fois que
vous utilisez, on le savait, on a on l'a
su dès que vous aviez le téléphone chez
vous hein, quand vous décrochez le
téléphone, bah on sait que vous êtes
chez vous. Donc voilà, vous étz que
quand il se trouve que la technologie de
la la technologie mobile fait qu'on a ce
qu'on appelle le serveur de
localisation, le serveur de localisation
qui est d'ailleurs un élément
extrêmement structurant euh fait qu'en
permanence, on est obligé d'identifier
là où vous êtes pour permettre de faire
sonner votre téléphone si quelqu'un
essaie de vous appeler.
Donc en permanence, un opérateur
télécomes
millions d'abonnés. En permanence,
vous savez comment on fait planter une
borne ? Oui, mais indépendamment de ça,
ça je je suis pas dans les contesures
qui fait que euh je peux même vous
raconter comment euh entre guillemets
euh on prend une borne et on s'est euh
reparamétré euh les cornées Lambaires
d'une borne euh pour faire croire que la
borne en réalité euh ne se trouve pas
dans les vauges mais dans les landes et
que à la fin ça perturbe toute l'in
d'information et que ça met un bazard
absolument.
Je vous jure monsieur le juge, on a
arrêté de faire ça.
Je je suis pas en train de de de parler
toujours de je dis juste la première
donnée, c'est la donnée de localisation.
Alors ces données de localisation, elles
sont pas propres aux opérateurs. Vous
faites un achat bancaire, on sait où
vous êtes.
Donc donc ça c'est la première donnée.
Et puis la deuxième donnée, bah
évidemment c'est vos temps d'usage,
c'est et c'est la nature de usage parce
que chaque requête que vous faites,
chaque appel que vous passez, tout est
enregistré.
Vous appelez quelqu'un, on sait qui vous
appelez. Alors, on le sait dans une
certaine mesure. On connaît le numéro de
téléphone éventuellement. À contrario,
on sait qui vous appelle. Alors, vous
allez me dire "Oui, mais en réalité
maintenant, on arrive à passer par des
applications qui font que en fait on
passe par WhatsApp, on passe par des des
d'autres systèmes et cetera bien sûr.
Mais de nouveau, pour être en capacité
d'exercer sur le territoire, en réalité,
on a qualifié ce type d'application,
on les a qualifié d'opérateur télécom
virtuel et donc on l'a redemandé de
respecter les mêmes obligations qui sont
de stocker les données et donc d'avoir
ça. C'est pour ça que je dis il faut pas
poser la question à Orange, poser la
question aux opérateurs en général et de
dire qu'est-ce qu'un opérateur ? un
opérateur, c'est quelqu'un qui met en
relation euh deux interlocuteurs, pas
forcément physique d'ailleurs, hein. Ça
peut être deux individus, ça peut être
un service et ça peut être un individu.
Euh et en fait, on a une capacité à
connaître toutes les requêtes que vous
faites, hein, puisque quand vous faites
une requête, vous tapez quelque chose,
il y a des paquets qui sont transmis, il
faut bien les acheminer quelque part.
Donc bah, quand vous tapez Google sur
votre interface, votre opérateur sait
qu'il faut appeler Google. Donc il va
rechercher où est-ce que le serveur de
Google est hébergé et cetera. Si vous
tapez si vous tapez TF1, bah il sait que
vous allez sur TF1. Donc globalement il
connaît une partie de votre activité. Ça
veut pas dire qu'il la traite parce que
il la traite pas en général. Enfin dans
nos pays démocratiques, je pense que ça
ne se traite pas. dans d'autres pays, ça
se traite. Je vous rappelle aussi que
nous sommes le pays et ça fait parfois
bondir un peu tout le monde. Nous sommes
le pays qui censurons le plus grand
nombre de sites euh parfois parfois à
juste titre hein, enfin même très
souvent à juste titre. Euh parfois on il
y a quelques cas qui qui sont plus
discutables mais euh euh mais euh nous
nous sommes nous sommes le pays qui euh
censurons le le plus de sites parce que
euh on censure les sites néonazies, on
censure les suites terroristes, on
censure euh pardon les
les sites pédophiles.
Les sites pédophiles, enfin on s'en on
censure de façon systématique que ceux
qu'on considère être contraire à
l'application de la loi. Et donc on ne
permet pas al évidemment vous allez me
dire on peut passer par les VPN et
cetera et cetera. Après c'est aussi une
forme de limitation. On peut toujours
trouver des moyens de détourner de toute
façon de de d'enfraindre à la loi. Mais
les principes fondamentaux c'est c'est
effectivement d'interdire ce qui n'est
pas légal et ce qu'on considère comme
n'est pas légal. Et moi personnellement,
j'y suis plutôt favorable. Après, il y a
des choses un peu plus discutables donc
pour qui sont qui sont parfois des
détails comme quoi
euh il y a des sujets sur lesquels on
peut discuter. Il y a il y a des il y a
des il y a des logiques de de de d'accès
à des à des contenus
euh piratés, non piratés. Bon, qui qui
pourrai poser qui pourrai poser quelques
quelques débats et et qui sont interdits
par la justice dans des conditions qui
sont des conditions plus de de de
discussion commerciale et sur lequel la
justice prend prend position, mais
ça nécesserait très une réflexion sur
une gouvernance un peu mondiale de
l'internet. Le problème c'est qu'on a
pas du tout le même rapport à la loi sur
une série de sujets. Donc donc c'est ce
serait des sujets compliqués et donc on
renvoie à la justice et pas forcément à
l'État parce que en fait on a deux
parties de de sites internet. On a des
sites internet censurés par l'État, on
va dire volontairement parce que ils
sont une atteinte à l'intégrité de notre
pays et puis on a des sites qui qui sont
rendus inaccessibles par décision de
justice. Et là là, ça renverrait sans
doute à une gouvernance un peu plus
globale notamment sur les questions de
droits d'auteur, sur les choses sujet
sur lesquels il y a il y a quelques
discussions qui mériteraient quand même
d'être un peu plus un peu plus
approfondies mais bon c'est compliqué
d'en discuter comme ça.
Donc voilà, donc un opérateur
globalement c'est beaucoup de choses de
votre vie.
C'est pour ça que théoriquement
dans la la quasi totalité des pays, le
le le sont effacées au bout d'un certain
temps parce qu'il faut permettre la
réquisition judiciaire mais au bout d'un
certain temps, on efface.
Donc donc tout tout ça s'efface. Il ne
reste pas moins que dans des pays peu
démocratiques. Bah on stock, on stock,
on stock, on stock et au final on est
capable de reconstituer l'activité que
vous avez eu sur 5, 10, 15 ans.
C'est ce qui se passe aux États-Unis,
je ne le pense pas. Je pense qu'il y a
d'autres pays plus totalit enfin tous
les cas, il y a des pays totalit qui le
font. Euh mais voilà, après non, je
pense pas que les États-Unis le fassent.
En France, on garde les les données
combien de temps ? Bah, il y a un
encadrement, il y a des encadrements
légaux qui définissent clairement les la
durée des données. Donc stocker les
données a aussi stocker les données a
aussi un coût hein. Stocker les données,
c'est des serveurs, c'est la
consommation électrique, c'est un centre
de sa donc on se on se on se limite
enfin je pense que les opérateurs se
limitent tous et pas qu'ange hein. Moi
je je connais pas c'est des sujets que
je connais pas que je ne pratique pas
mais je pense que tous les opérateurs se
limitent au strict minimum pour des
questions purement économique.
Chez Orange, il y a des protocoles ou
des exercices
de mise sous contrainte de votre
infrastructure, de votre personnel en
cas de guerre, en cas de tempête
solaire, d'inondation, d'arrivée
d'extraterrestre ou je ne sais quoi.
Ah, tous les opérateurs euh tous les
opérateurs à la fois euh de façon
indépendante et euh avec l'État euh se
livre à des exercices euh de
sécurisation et de stabilisation de
leurs infrastructures.
Euh prenons par exemple la CRU de 1910.
Euh aujourd'hui, on sait tous qu'on a
des exercices imposés aux opérateurs de
se dire qu'est-ce qui se passe si la
scène monte au niveau de 1970 de 1910.
Et qu'est-ce qui se passe sur les
infrastructures ? Ça c'est des questions
qui se posent systématiquement. Alors,
les opérateurs en font une partie. Euh,
l'État fait d'autres exercices, il y a
des coordinations, mais c'est vrai pour
tous les infrastructures vital. Euh,
Orange et et tous les opérateurs sont
déclarés comme opérateur d'intérêt
vital. Donc, les exercices de de de mise
en stress, hein, ce qu'on appelle mise
en stress sont faites pour que on soit
le plus résilient possible. Euh pour
autant euh pour autant euh l'impossible
euh l'impossible peut arriver. Euh et
euh et on a aussi des accidents, on a eu
quelques grandes pannes, on a eu
quelques grandes pannes imprévisibles ou
imprévues euh qui euh qui sont arrivés
euh euh malgré beaucoup de précautions
qui qui avaient été prises, mais ça
arrive chez tous les opérateurs euh et
et
nous avons des systèmes qui sont
fragiles. Évidemment, c'est un
retentissement extrêmement fort. Pour
autant, on a une stabilité absolument
extraordinaire
de nos réseaux dans dans notre pays.
Est-ce qu'il y a un sujet qu'on a pas
abordé que vous souhaiteriez aborder
avec nous ? Qu' un truc qui vous tient à
cœur ? Ah, chez Orange, on fait du PE
test.
Est-ce que vous vous mettez euh avec des
équipes pour tester votre robustesse ?
Laquelle ? C'est le notre organisation
syndicale. Euh euh non,
empoisonnement de données si vous
voulez, on discute des empoisonnements
de données de du mois des empoisonnement
de données qui entraînent les IA.
Oui. Alors, on revient sur le sujet de
l'IA. Moi, je crois que l'A générative
est morte mais elle est morte née. Elle
elle s'autoent intoxique.
Oui. Alors, j'ai j'ai créé un papier ça
sur sur l'op l'anthrophagie de l'IA.
générative, hein générative euh en
milieu ouvert euh en milieu fermé, c'est
pas le cas. Euh
l'IA Générative euh c'est une c'est un
concept qui est né il y a une dizaine
d'années euh sur une conceptualisation
du langage euh
qui est une vraie rupture
épistémologique euh qui est une vraie
rupture épistémologique. On a
on a essayé de non pas de comprendre la
signification des mots ou en tous les
cas de l'analyser comme étant
significatif, mais on a essayé de les
relier les uns avec les autres et on a
utilisé des logiques statistiques pour
essayer de reconstituer des textes à la
base sur la base de millions de de
textes déjà préécrits.
Et donc c'est une vraie révolution parce
que moi qui ai fait de l'intelligence
artificielle assez tôt de la
reconnaissance vocale, de la
reconnaissance visuelle, des tas de
sujets, des réseaux neuronaux déjà.
C'est en quelle langue ? euh en Ada à
l'époque.
Euh
moi je déteste coder, je suis un très
mauvais codeur. Euh je le regrette
d'ailleurs. Euh je maîtrise à peine je
maîtrise à peine une demi-dzaine de
langages. Euh ouais, mais c'est très peu
pour un codeur à la base parce que tout
codeur tout codeur
tout codeur de qualité en maîtrise en
maîtrise au moins une douzaine enfin moi
je considère alors après ça veut pas
dire qu'on a pas ces langages de
prédiction mais
entre vous ça va très vite hein vous
faites du basique vous faites du C vous
faites du Lispe vous faites de la DAT
vous faites du binaire bon voilà vous y
êtes à la demiine euh Donc donc
vous auriez plus de vu en cobol ou des
trucs comme ça.
Ouais, j'aurais voilà j'en maîtrise
absolument pas mais mais vous voyez vous
voyez à quel point ça va vite et et donc
et donc les vrais codeurs puis en plus
moi je l'ai oublié
je l'ai oublié. Alors certes, je parle
quatre langues mais mais mais je suis un
très mauvais codeur
et j'ai pas d'appétence particulière
pour le pour le codage et je le regrette
parce que parce que c'est un c'est un
univers fabuleux.
Euh mais euh mais finalement euh euh
mais finalement oui, pour en revenir à à
cette question de de l'intoxication des
données, puisqueon finalement on peut
parler d'intoxication des données, euh
le le cette modification de la
perception du du enfin de la
conceptualisation du langage a conduit
effectivement à ce qu'on on arrive à une
production tout à fait stupéfiante
qu'elle a générative et donc la
production de de texte. mais on l'a fait
euh sur la base euh de données ouvertes.
Ces données ouvertes euh en réalité euh
sont en nombre extrêmement euh
restreints euh et donc euh et donc euh
en tous les cas des données fiables sont
nombre extrêmement restreints. Euh donc
le le résultat est que
les I sont allés chercher les I
génératifs sont allés chercher des
données non fiables euh et ces données
non fiables ont commençai à polluer de
façon massive ont commençait à polluer
de façon massive les résultats.
Donc malgré l'amélioration des
algorithmes,
le la dégradation de la qualité des
données qui est arrivé parce qu'on a une
on a une espèce d'inflation des données,
hein, je dire une augmentation
des données. Je je sais plus, on disait
je crois qu'on prenait alors c'est des
exemples de de l'ordre mais on disait en
2000 on prenait un milliard de photos
par an, aujourd'hui on en prend un
milliard par jour. enfin des des
proportions qui sont qui sont
désirantes. Euh mais euh je encore je
suis pas sûr des chiffres, les chiffres
sont pas sont pas exacts, mais enfin
c'est pour donner les dimensions par
heure. Enfin, en tous les cas, c'est
c'est les c'est les proportions qui sont
absolument démantes. Euh malgré ça,
malgré ça, on se rend compte que dès
qu'on commence à serrer les sujets,
qu'on commence à serrer les sujets, on
s'aperçoit que le nombre de données est
assez faible. Et donc euh l'intoxication
des données est assez facile à faire. Et
de la
Qui intoxique ?
Tout le monde. Tout le monde. Euh on
intoxique par bêtises,
on intoxique par ignorance, euh on
par idéologie
par idéologie. Euh on intoxique par
malveillance. Euh donc on intoxique, on
intoxique, on intoxique. Euh et euh
il est tellement plus facile euh de
financer la malveillance que de financer
la bienveillance
euh que les données sont malheureusement
extrêmement polluées. Et je dirais même
pire,
il y a une fameuse fable qui disait déjà
du temps des Grecs que il suffisait
d'une cuillère de goudron pour gâcher un
baril de miel.
Donc
on en est là. Donc en fait l'AG
générative n'a pas d'avenir. Les euh les
les les acharnements qu'on a euh les
acharnements qu'on a euh sur générative
sur des sujets un peu pointus euh
ouverts sont son sont son sont son sont
son sont son sont son sont son sont son
sont son vein son vin. Euh en revanche,
ce qu'il faut se dire c'est que l'IA en
tant que tel fait des progrès
considérables
dans des environnements fermés.
Alors avec des biaiss, je vais en donner
un exemple qui est extrêmement
inquiétant euh mais qui est intéressant
néanmoins, c'est dans un environnement
fermé de détection des cancers du poumon
sur la base de radio. Euh LIA LIA
détecte plus de cancer de poumon qu'un
médecin
radiologue.
Ah oui, qu'un qu'un oncologue.
Euh donc ça c'est déjà un phénomène
interpellant. Donc la question c'est
dire il vaut mieux se faire détecter son
cancer de du poumon euh par une machine
que par un médecin. Oui, mais euh on a
pensé
que euh
les 97 ou 98 % euh des cancers détectés
incluaient les 95 % détectés par le
médecin ou l'encolo ? Et la réponse est
non.
les cancers non détectés, c'est-à-dire
les 2 3 % moins ou les 5 % ne sont pas
les mêmes.
Et ça c'est un phénomène assez
fascinant. Ça veut dire que
l'intelligence humaine eton en a pas
parlé tout à l'heure sur la question de
l'IA, c'est quand même le produit de 200
millions d'années d'évolution
et de sélection naturelle.
Le numérique c'est 100 ans.
Alors vous allez me dire d'un côté c'est
la biologie de l'autre que c'est du
numérique. Oui d'accord mais il ne reste
pas moins que c'est quand même 200
millions d'années et que le rapport
entre 200 millions d'années et 100 ans,
il est quand même extrêmement important.
C'est quand même un facteur c'est quand
même un facteur qui est considérablement
élevé.
Euh et la question qu'on s'est posée,
c'est dire bah pourquoi il y a des
cancers qui sont détectés par les
médecins et qui sont pas détectés par
que quelque part euh les oncologues ont
une expérience, une habitude, euh
s'interroge,
travaill et donc détecte des cancers
atypiques. Alors on s'est dit
on va mettre ces cancers atypiques dans
la machine pour en faire une machine
apprenante. Oui. petit problème, c'est
que les cancers atypiques, ils sont
atypiques, donc leur caractère de
reproductivité est pas là. Donc d'un
point de vue statistique, ça marche pas.
Donc on améliore pas le système.
Donc en fait la question qui est posée,
c'est euh quand vous avez la radio des
poumons pour savoir si vous avez un
cancer, faut-il faire confiance à la
machine ? Faut-il faire confiance à
l'être humain ? Reste une question qui
est posée parce que si vous êtes dans
les cancers atypiques, vous ne serez pas
détecté. par la machine. Euh si vous
êtes dans les cancers classiques, vous
serez détequé mieux par la machine.
Donc évidemment ça vous interroge. Et
alors le plus frappant c'est derrière le
comportement
des oncologues aujourd'hui face à
l'intelligence artificielle et les et la
question générationnelle qui nous doit
nous interroger sur le comportement de
la société en général dans la confiance
que nous avons dans les politi
numériques.
On considère qu'un oncologue qui a moins
de 45 ans va d'abord lire le résultat de
la machine
puis ensuite regarder la radio. Et on
considère qu'un oncologue de plus de 45
ans ou 50 ans va d'abord regarder la
radio avant de regarder le résultat.
Donc le biais cognitif
consiste à dire qu'il y a un risque et
les études évidemment on n' pas assez de
recul fait que l'oncologue qui regarde
les résultats de la machine qui dit
qu'il n'y a pas de cancer
se trompe parce qu'il fait confiance à
la machine.
Alors que l'oncologue qui aura regardé
la radio avant de regarder le résultat
détectera des cancers qu'il aurait pas
détecté s'il avait le résultat.
Et donc notre biais cognitif par rapport
au numérique est un biais extrêmement
dangereux
dans la détection de de ce type de
phénomène. Donc ça doit nous interroger
sur notre rapport au numérique, à la
confiance qu'on accorde au numérique et
ça revient à la fameuse question
l'enseignement.
C'est deux choses, la transmission du
savoir, l'esprit critique.
Et ben, on n'est pas dans la merde.
Question internet. Bonsoir. Que pense
monsieur Crosier de l'épidémie de fuite
de données en France actuellement ?
Objectivement,
peut-être qu'elles sont un peu plus
médiatisé.
Peut-être qu'elles sont un peu plus
médiatisées.
Peut-être qu'on est obligé de maintenant
de communiquer. Peut-être que maintenant
on est obligé de communiquer.
Je suis pas sûr. Je suis pas sûr que les
fuites de données n'aient pas existé, y
compris du temps du papier. Je vous
rappelle quand même que si les broyeurs
ont été inventés sur le papier, c'est
justement pour éviter que on récupère
dans les poubelles euh les informations
qui qui étaient mises dans une série
d'institutions qui traitaient des
données à caractère personnel.
Donc il y a un enjeu euh mais là ça
renvoie à un sujet qu'on a pas évoqué
tout à l'heure vous posz la question
qu'est-ce que vous voudriez aborder
comme sujet ? Je crois que le numérique
nous a apporté une catastrophe,
c'est celle de la complexité.
La catastrophe de la complexité, c'est
que nous avons cru que le numérique
allait nous permettre de faire des
choses
entre guillemets soi-disant plus justes
et en fait finalement de gérer une
complexité qui nous permettait de gérer
des cas particuliers.
C'est pas du tout le cas.
Et nous n'avons cessé parallèlement au
développement numérique à voir la
complexité
se développer et donc au final nous
avons une régression de la capacité des
individus à comprendre le monde dans
lequel ils vivent. Je vais vous donner
un exemple. Je ne prendrai pas l'exemple
des impôts. Je pense que chaque citoyen
n'est plus en capacité de comprendre ce
que c'est qu'une feuille d'impôt. Mais
ça fait longtemps.
Une question avant que vous commenciez.
Vous gagnez combien ?
Monse République, il suffit d'aller le
chercher sur chat GPT puisque étant
administrateur du groupe Orange, mon
salaire est déclaré.
Et ceux qui n'ont pas de chat GPT comme
ma grand-mère, ma grand-mère a chat GPT
et ben elle tape orange.com, elle va
chercher conseil d'administration, la
déclaration, le rapport annuel et et il
y a mon salaire à l'intérieur.
Donc c'est simple. Euh donc il y pas de
rappelz pas
de quoi ? De mon salaire.
Ouis.
Bah c'est-à-dire que en fait on a trois
salaires. Euh on a un salaire brut, on a
un salaire net puis on a un salaire à
post impôt. Je vous avoue que je je ne
sais même plus quel est mon salaire brut
dans ce bazar. Donc je sais que mon
salaire brut il est écrit parce que
c'est celui qui est déclaré. Et je sais
que globalement celui que je touche par
moi sur ma fiche de paye. Mais je je ne
sais même plus je ne connais plus mon
salaire brut. Je ne connais plus mon
salaire net après charge sociale et
avant impôt. C'est tellement on est dans
le prélèbre à la source et cetera,
tellement la complexité est au
rendez-vous.
C'est un problème de riche.
Non, c'est pas un problème de riche.
C'est la matérialisation du fait que la
complexité oberre notre capacité de
compréhension du monde et que
aujourd'hui tout le monde se préoccupe
de la même chose, c'est de son pouvoir
d'achat. Et son pouvoir d'achat, c'est
ce qu'on a après les impôts. Donc en
fait le il y a pas de problème de riche.
il y a combien j'ai donc je sais combien
tombe tous les mois sur mon compte en
banque et je sais ce qu'avec ce avec cet
argent qui tombe tous les mois sur le
compte en banque j'ai mes charges fixe
mes charges variables et donc et donc je
je variabilise et combien je mets en
épargne ou combien je mets pas en
épargne. Et encore euh il se trouve que
chez Orange qui est une entreprise qui
utilise un nombre de mécanismes qui sont
mis à disposition des entreprises pour
rétribuer ces personnels. intéressement,
participation, action gratu et cetera.
Euh à la fin, on ne sait plus très bien
combien on épargne. C'est quand même
aussi un autre problème de la
complexité. C'estàd que aujourd'hui on
est à ça. Mais l'exemple que je voulais
vous donner et sur lesquel vous m'avez
interpu, c'est dire il y a 30 ans, une
fiche de paye ça se faisait sur un
papier carbone.
On écrivait la fiche de paye, on avait
quelques taux de cotisation,
on payait son collaborateur avec une
fiche de paye qui était écrite à la
main,
qui aujourd'hui est capable d'écrire une
fiche de paye à la main en tant
qu'employeur.
Je compléterai si vous m'autorisez.
en tant que patron qui peut se passer
d'un expert comptable
les bons patrons.
Ce qu'on du temps. C'est ça.
C'est ça.
Voilà.
Non mais ça ça c'est c'est un autre
sujet. C'est c'est la question de la
complexité du temps. Mais et la question
qui est posée quand on la pose, c'est
pour ça que vous vous me posez la
question sur les sujets qui peuvent qui
peuvent avoir un intérêt pour moi et qui
peuvent animer à la fois ce lien entre
la technologie, la société et
l'engagement
social.
C'est dire
pourquoi passe-t-on notre temps à se
complexifier ? Pourquoi passe-ton notre
temps à créer des univers de plus en
plus complexes ?
Si on prend une fiche de paye et et elle
est dévoyée, c'est un sujet qui est
intéressant,
au final, une fiche de paye ça sert à
quoi ? Ça sert à payer bien sûr les
individus avec un salaire net à la fin
qui est tout en bas, mais ça sert aussi
à apporter des contributions
de deux natures. Alors, c'est là où on a
déjà introduit une complexité,
des natures qui sont des salaires
différés.
et ensuite des contributions qui sont en
réalité des impôts.
Pourquoi ? Parce que quand vous regardez
votre fiche de paye et vous regardez les
taxes ou les cotisations, on va dire les
cotisations salariales et patronales qui
sont dedans, vous en avez je crois cinq
cinq catégories.
La maladie,
tout le monde est malade dans ce pays.
Où l'it à un moment et pas plus que
d'autres ?
Oui, mais Bismarc avait considéré
d'ailleurs qu'il fallait avoir un
système d'assurance maladie pour les
pauvres et pas pour les riches. Ce qui
est assez intéressant comme concept.
Considérant que les riches pouvaient se
payer leur système de santé tandis que
les pauvres ne le pouvaient pas. Donc on
organisait en fait un système de
sécurité sociale pour les PAV. Euh donc
la maladie, si ça concerne tout le
monde, pourquoi l'asseoir sur le salaire
puisqueen réalité c'est la société et
les citoyens qu'on finance. La deuxième
c'est les allocations familiales. De
nouveau les allocations familiales, ça
concerne tous les citoyens. C'est donc
pas une cotisation
euh qui est liée au travail mais qui est
lié à la société. Donc pourquoi le
mettre sur la fiche de pay ? Et puis
après, on a trois cotisations qui sont
très différentes qui sont la prévoyance.
La première, c'est quand on est malade,
c'est quand on n'est pas en capacité de
travailler et là c'est du salaire
différé.
On a ensuite
les caisses de retraite. Là, c'est du
salaire différé. Le travail qu'on a
produit pendant sa vie nous permet
d'assurer notre retraite et donc
d'assurer une forme de rente. Et les
cotisation chômage euh qui sont pendant
les périodes de chômage, on a quand même
une indemnité qui nous permet de vivre
un temps donné plus ou moins long en
fonction des des évolutions
gouvernementales et donc c'est une
troisème cotisation. Donc on voit bien
qu'en fait on a un problème sur cette
fiche de paye qui à la base déjà est
assez simple. cinq cotisations,
deux qui sont faites qui ne devraient
pas être des cotisations qui sont des
impôts et euh de l'autre côté trois
cotisations qui sont du salaire différé.
Euh malgré ces principes très simples
qui ferait qu'on devrait euh sortir deux
deux cotisations du système de paye et
de ne laisser que celles qui sont des
salaires différés, on a quand même
réussi à à faire une fiche de paye que
plus personne n'est capable de lire
et le numérique a rendu ça possible.
Donc en réalité, nous avons exclu nous
avons exclu par la complexité une partie
de la population à comprendre le monde
dans lequel il vit.
C'est fait à dessin votre avis ?
C'est une question intéressante. La
question c'est est-ce que c'est un
phénomène anthropologique qui vise
depuis le début des temps euh de faire
que le savoir soit réservé à une élite
euh qui permet de de de de gouverner le
monde. La question de par exemple
apprendre à lire et à écrire a été un
long débat. ceux qui savaient lire et
écrire avaient le pouvoir.
Euh le jour où on a rendu l'école
obligatoire, on a rendu la diffusion de
certaines idées possibles. Le jour où on
a décidé de faire l'imprimerie et
caractè les caractères mobiles avec
Gutinber,
on a permis de vulgariser
l'enseignement de de la Bible et on a
d'ailleurs créé une catastrophe
importante puisque ça a permis les
gardes de religion euh quelques quelques
décennies plus tard. Donc voilà, donc
c'est c'est des débats qui sont
intéressants, c'est est-ce que
l'augmentation permanente de euh ces
progrès technologiques et de de cette de
ces euh
de cette de cette complexité qu'on qu'on
organise
est en fait une façon de restreindre
ceux qui sont en capacité de de
maîtriser le monde. Question internet.
Quels sont les pouvoirs d'action
d'Orange en matière de DPI, DIP, Paquet,
Inspection et de surveillance de la
population en tant que fournisseur
d'accès internet ? Et l'entreprise
est-elle en train de devenir complice du
renseignement ou de la censure du pays
entre parenthèses, VPN, DNS et cetera et
cetera ?
Moi, je répondrai ce que j'ai répondu,
ce que j'ai répondu de nouveau dans le
monde il y a une dizaine d'années, les
opérateurs font ce que les États
demandent.
Voilà.
Et les lanceurs d'alerte dans
bah les lanceurs d'alerte, c'est quand
quand à l'intérieur d'une entreprise
des acteurs quelconque voient des choses
qui euh leur paraissent contraires euh
au au cadre réglementaire, enfin plus et
plutôt au cadre légal. euh sonne
l'alarme
et c'est leur rôle. Enfin, en tous les
cas et moi je j'invite et moi j'invite
chaque euh j'invite chaque citoyen dans
son entreprise qui constate que parce
qu'il y a pas que les opérateurs hein,
il y a toute une série d'acteurs qui qui
sont en capacité de de de surveillance.
Euh je dis en capacité hein, j'ai pas
dit qui qui surveillait euh de de de
lancer l'alerte les vidéos les les la
vidéosurveillance. Euh combien de
dérives attend sur la vidéosurveillance
? ou le stockage excès de les délais
réglementaires
et cetera et cetera. Donc oui, moi
j'invite chaque citoyen à à se
manifester dès lors que il constate
quelque chose qui est pas dans le cadre
réglementaire et cadre légal. Oui.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à nous
à nous conseiller et à conseiller à
notre communauté ?
Alors là, je vois qu'on arrive à la fin
de nos conversations et
Ouais. 2h53 Sébastien. Oh !
Euh, mais vous m'aviez promis que je
battrai l'ambassadeur chinois ? Ah non
non, j'ai jamais promis ça.
Ne me faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas
dit. Je respecte toujours ma parole.
Alors attention,
peut-être Et moi aussi j'ai le droit de
j'ai le droit aussi de de challenger le
le celui- qui a regardé des choses de
chez nous avant.
Oui oui oui.
Lesquels ?
Du pontel
Albert. Extraordinaire. C'était j'ai
j'ai mis un certain temps donc j'ai j'ai
choisi le mode accéléré
euh mais euh d'autres
mais euh
mais évidemment alors si on les met dans
le même axe euh c'est ces trois livres
qui permettent de comprendre une partie
du monde.
euh l'art de la guerre euh
ça permet de gérer les affrontements et
de comprendre la géopolitique du monde
actuel. Nous sommes en guerre. Nous
avons toujours été en guerre depuis la
nuit des temps. Depuis que
l'homme a dépassé
un espace,
on va dire légitime d'occupation du
territoire, nous sommes en guerre.
Et donc la préoccupation de de captation
du territoire euh
est arrivé et donc la la guerre est
arrivée.
Donc Sensu est intéressant parce qu'il
permet de comprendre une partie de la
géopolitique du monde et des opérations
qui sont menées par les grands acteurs
qui qui nous dirigent.
Le deuxème évidemment dans la même
lignée
avant avant le deuxè donc vous parlez de
neuf terrains là. Alors, il y a les neuf
terrains, mais il y a pas que ça. Il y a
il y a le l'idée que
on on doit d'abord avant avant
l'affrontement tout moyen, le principe
de Sunsu, c'est en substance, c'est tout
moyen doit être utilisé avant
l'affrontement.
Et il y a des pages et des pages
entières sur les différentes techniques
euh pour euh arriver à ne pas aller à
l'affrontement.
Vous savez pourquoi ?
Parce que l'affrontement est toujours le
moment le plus dangereux est toujours le
moment le plus dangereux pour les deux
parties.
À Zincour,
les Français sont sûrs de gagner. C'est
un désastre militaire.
Donc en fait, on ne sait jamais on ne
sait jamais si on va gagner. Donc il ne
faut jamais aller à l'affrontement.
Donc euh pour ne jamais l'affrontement,
on utilise toutes les méthodes pour
éviter de violer.
Euh
ça c'est le le c'est c'est c'est
toujours c'est facile à lire, pas facile
à comprendre toujours parce qu'il faut
du temps, faut le relire plusieurs fois,
faut le relire à plusieurs âges.
Mais ça permet de comprendre que
l'affrontement et et le stade ultime
et le stade ultime et donc il faut tout
faire pour pour l'éviter ou en tous les
cas
si on a la volonté de de gagner ce qui
est pas toujours ce qui est pas toujours
la la volonté des parties.
Il faut il faut le lire.
Maabelle est intéressant parce que dans
l'air dans l'aire de la manipulation,
dans l'air des fake news,
dans l'air de la c'est l'époque de c'est
l'époque de Laurent Missis hein. Donc
c'est c'est une époque fabuleuse, c'est
une extrêmement riche, c'est une extrême
créative. C'est à la fois la beauté d'un
Botit Chelly euh euh où euh où on a euh
à la fois deux périodes hein chez B
Chelly où euh avant Savonarol euh on on
il peint il peint des des des il peint
des personnages
des vêtus ou voirnus et puis après sa
vonarole euh il plonge dans une sorte de
mystisisme religieux. Euh mais en tout
cas, c'est une époque fabuleuse. C'est
une époque de la naissance, c'est une
époque de l'émergence du du monde
occidental telle qu'on le connaît et euh
et et pas grand-chose n'a changé depuis
Maavel. Donc c'est c'est intéressant et
c'est intéressant aussi de comprendre
euh les logiques de manipulation qu' est
soumis parce que en le lisant, on
comprend et on peut décrypter euh
comment euh les opérations euh se font,
se défont, ce qu'on lit, d'où c'est
organisé, d'où ça vient, comment c'est
construit. Euh et on pourrait donner 1
exemple. Et la troisième chose, c'est de
comprendre que alors après évidemment on
pourrait dire F Krig F Krig euh en
allemand
qui est en fait de Clauswitz qui est qui
est finalement un traité sur la guerre,
une guerre assez moderne, une guerre
qui qui est la dernière qui qui où il
écrit ça en fait après la dernière
guerre presque traditionnelle hein qui
qui est celle de 1870.
euh où en fait la guerre en fait n'est
qu'un instrument d'une d'une logique
politique et d'une ambition politique.
Et ça c'est intéressant parce que ça
veut dire euh évidemment ce sont des des
livres qui sont écrits à des époques
très différentes euh qui se relient
finalement les uns aux autres. Alors
dire que c'est trois livres qui
inspireraient euh la façon dont dont
dont dont je vivrais la réponse est non
euh parce que ce n'est que on va dire
une une partie de de de ce que de ce que
je suis. Mais euh mais ce qui est
intéressant, c'est de comprendre que le
monde va vers de plus en plus de
violence, que la guerre euh même si elle
est à bas bruit, elle est constante et
permanente. Euh
nous n'avons quasiment pas de période
sans guerre
depuis
la sortie de la deuxème guerre mondiale.
Il y a forcément une guerre quelque part
dans le monde qui se passe et qui se
déroule.
Euh donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
comprendre que ces guerres ne sont qu'en
fait un instrument au service de
politique d'acteurs qu'on ne voit pas
forcément.
Et donc c'est une façon de comprendre
euh que le le le monde en guerre est en
fait la la poursuite d'objectifs
politiques euh des uns des autres euh
d'acteurs qui sont pas apparents euh
mais le monde n'a jamais arrêté d'être
en guerre en tous les cas. Euh sur les
80 dernières années, je crois que c'est
trois livres qui permettent de donner
une compréhension du monde dans lequel
on vit. Après, il y en a d'autres.
Voilà. Après moné des trois, moi je
trouve que c'est c'est c'est ces trois
livres qui s'inscrivent dans une lignée
dans une lignée
et moi je me sens pas je me sens pas en
capacité de de d'appréhender certains
philosophes plutôt que d'autres sur le
sur leur profondeur d'analyse. Je me
sens très très démuni euh parfois par
rapport à certains ouvrages
philosophiques sur lesquels je m'y
reprends à plusieurs fois avant de les
lire parce que je me demande qu'est-ce
qui est signifié. Après, il y a il y a
des il y a des il y a des il y a des
livres très drôles à lire. Moi, je
trouve que la société du spectacle de
Guid Bord est extrêmement drôle à lire
parce que finalement il décrit avec des
des années d'avance ce qui ce qui ce qui
se passe actuellement.
La ferme La ferme des animaux,
pardon.
La ferme des animaux.
Ah oui, la ferme. Ah oui, évidemment.
Alors après si on rentre dans on va dire
dans dans ce que j'appelle la la les
livres fictions
euh ce que j'appelle les livres fiction
mais c'est qui on qui sont qui sont là
évidemment on a on a on a deux auteurs
qui sont enfin trois auteurs même si
deux sont très liés l'un à l'autre qui
est évidemment Alou Clay et et George
Well he puisque l'un était l'élève de
l'autre euh le le le avec le meilleur
des mondes qui qui sans doute nous
apparaît plus décalé, mais euh dont la
dont la finesse et et et la profondeur
est quand même réelle. Euh l'idée
que on produit des êtres humains euh
dont la capacité
organique est identique à l'origine,
mais dans lesquelles on les intoxique
volontairement pour en faire des
sous-hommes est un phénomène fascinant,
est une idée fascinante. Vous
êtes sûr que c'est une fiction ?
à son époque. Oui.
Euh, évidemment Horwell est plus
classique parce que 1984 a été vu,
décortiqué, analysé et cetera. Mais
relire le meilleur des mondes, c'est
intéressant parce qu'il y a des idées
qui sont euh extrêmement violentes, euh
extrêmement brutales et qui nous
ramènent parfois au réel.
Et après, il y a un troisème auteur de
science-fiction ou de livre fiction et
peut-être plus encore de science-fiction
que de que de livre fiction euh qui est
sans doute Philippe Cadic.
Euh alors, évidemment, mort très jeune,
euh complètement euh complètement
euh euh complètement défoncé au LSD euh
mais écrivant euh des phénomènes tout à
fait fascinants euh sur
des des sujets comme la loterie
démocratique, euh sur des sujets comme
qui interrogent, qui réinterrogent, sur
la question de l'ubiquité
sur des sur des sujets de de la de la
alors évidemment dont dont on a fait des
des films dont fait des films
extrêmement connus mais là là je parlais
des des livres des livres un peu moins
connus mais tout le monde connaît tout
le monde connaît Blade Runner qui qui
est issu d'une nouvelle et pas d'un
livre tout le monde connaît aussi
tout le monde connaît aussi l'autre
livre avec les les précogues là ceux qui
prédisent l'avenir mais en réalité où où
d'ailleurs les expéri expérience, c'est
c'est amusant parce que
le le parallélisme avec les expériences
qui ont été menées par la police de
Jeanles qui avec de de des logiques de
de d'IA prédictiv,
ça a été ça a été adapté ça a été adapté
avec Tom Cruise.
Oui. Oui. Alors, j'ai j'ai plus le nom
en tête. J'ai plus le nom en tête. J'ai
j'ai plus le nom en tête.
Ça commence par un M
euh Minority Report. Euh et donc euh et
donc évidemment c'est c'est des livres
qui sont euh alors les les les euh il
vaut mieux d'ailleurs lire les nouvelles
euh que regarder les films euh pour des
tas de raisons parce que les films sont
évidemment scénarisés euh pour en faire
des bestselleriens et euh et la pensée
profonde de l'auteur en est trahie. Elle
est peut-être moins dans Blade Runner
d'ailleurs que dans que dans que que
dans Min minority Report. Euh mais euh
mais mais c'est intéressant, c'estàdire
l'idée euh de ces euh de de ces
créations euh d'humain euh finalement
euh
hypersensible. Oui, enfin déconnecté
enfin qui qui finalement une logique de
de de mortalité organisée,
programmé dont on voit bien qu'en fait
c'est c'est une dissociation sociale
qu'on qu'on a organisé dans la société.
Euh et et en fait en fait nous projette
dans des univers extrêmement violents
euh mais donc des ressemblance avec le
monde actuel, l'hypersurveillance euh la
la machine euh les machines alors
évidemment c'est c'est des caricatures
mais la machine qui reconnaît
immédiatement euh le visiteur qui arrive
dans le magasin pour lui conseiller les
produits qui dont il a besoin parce
qu'il a fait une reconnaissance faciale
ou une reconnaissance optique euh c'est
des réalités qui sont pas mises en œuvre
parce que parce que on se dit que
finalement les l'efficacité
opérationnelle, l'acceptabilité serait
pas au rendez-vous. Mais mais c'est des
sujets intéressants. Il y a des il y a
des films qui nous parlent de voiture
autonome. Voiture autonome aujourd'hui,
c'est une réalité. Vous allez me dire
non, on va pas avoir d'acceptation sur
les voitures autonomes. Si on va avoir
une acceptation de voiture autonome
parce que le jour où un régime
autoritaire aura imposé la voiture
autonome et aura démontré qu'il y a
trois fois moins de morts avec un
algorithme un peu correct que de
chauffeur alcoolique, bah il va falloir
faire comme un choix éthique qui est
est-ce qu'on préfère être tué par un
algorithme avec une chance sur 10 de
moins de mourir ou par un chauffeur
alcoolique qui vous a percuté votre
voiture parce que il était un livre
mort. Euh donc on va avoir des choix
éthiques de société. Donc toutes ces
questions-là, elles sont déjà posées en
fait dans dans dans le dans les ouvrages
de de fiction, d'anticipation et et
c'est des sources de d'inspiration, de
réflexion sur la société de demain, sur
ses dérives. Bon, je parle pas de
l'héroïque fantaisie, je parle pas de
tout ça qui qui présente peu d'intérêt,
enfin à mes yeux en terme de de de mais
voilà, on a des auteurs qui qui sont des
auteurs de de quel qu'on a qu'on
qualifie de science-fiction mais
meilleur pour ça moi j'appelle des
auteurs de fiction et pas des auteurs de
science-fiction euh mais fiction ou sens
société de demain euh qui sont qui sont
assez profonds mais qui se qui se voilà
donc si j'avais à dire entre guillemets
trois livres en fait entre les cas trois
ou en tous les cas deux filières qui qui
m'ont inspiré.
Une façon de décrire le monde
et une façon de d'envisager le monde.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose qui restera
impérissable sur les réseaux.
Un conseil pour les jeunes,
n'ayez pas de certitude. N'ayez pas de
certitude.
Jamais dans l'histoire de l'humanité,
quelque chose ne ne s'est avéré certain.
On pensait que la pomme de Newton
c'était la fin et la démonstration que
la gravité
la gravité newtionnienne était l'alpha
et l'oméga toute chose. La relativité
restreinte puis plus générale de
d'Einstein montré que c'était pas vrai.
Euh en permanence euh le monde a changé.
Euh en permanence, on a remis en cause
euh nos certitudes et nous n'avons
jamais eu rien dans l'histoire de
l'humanité qui puisse dont on puisse
démontrer que ça a été stable. Donc
n'ayez pas de certitude. Remettez-vous
tout le temps en cause. Remettez en
cause ce qu'on vous dit. Remettez en
cause euh ce que vous voyez. Remettez en
cause ce que vous lisez. Remettez en
cause euh ça veut pas dire ne croyez pas
à ce que vous lisez. Mais faites- en
vous-même votre propre opinion, votre
propre analyse, accumuler la
connaissance
pour être en capacité de critiquer,
d'analyser
pour que vos vos certitudes
deviennent des incertitudes, mais que
ces incertitudes pour autant ne vous
déstabilisent pas.
Sébastien Crosier, merci.
Merci beaucoup.